guys whoops sorry professional VTuber here guys sorry double tap the screen guys remember to double tap the screen guys
Okay.
Sorry.
I had a whole fucking side quest today.
So that's why I was late.
I had to accept a side quest where I actually had to go outside and like walk to the post office.
My fucking Google Maps lied to me.
It was like, it's going to be like 10 minutes.
It was like, oh, maybe I'm just a very slow walker.
Uh, but it was not 10 minutes.
It did not feel like 10 minutes.
Um, the reason why I went to the post office, they're like, you must be like wondering, why didn't you go to the post office earlier, Doki?
You pin, you like had that pin message, um, on like, like two, like two hours before the stream was supposed to start.
Um, it's, uh, it's because, um, I have a very good reason.
I have a very good reason.
Master Job, thank you for the 50 gifted ships.
Thank you.
Oh my God.
That's so many gifted.
Thank you so much, everybody.
Okay.
I have like a very perfectly good reason that has nothing to do with laziness.
And like, it is very reasonable why, like I went to the post office that late.
So the reason why was because I woke up at 3 p.m.
and, um, I ordered food.
I, okay.
I had to like do my error.
I had to do like the morning routine stuff.
So then I ordered food at, uh, at like, uh, 3.30 and, um, I ordered food at 3.30 and then it just got delayed until, and it wasn't going to arrive until like 4.30.
So I was like, fuck.
I thought it would arrive sooner.
So I was like, okay.
Okay.
So I went to the post office, like, uh, now after I ordered food, like maybe like it'll arrive earlier.
So like, I couldn't take the risk.
I couldn't take the risk.
So I have to wait until the food arrived, uh, munch it down for like, eat the food for 10 minutes and then, uh, and then walk to the post office.
Um, a very brisk walk too, by the way.
Anyway, so that is why, that is why, um, that is why I was late.
That is why I was late.
Also, I also had a side quest.
uh, were, I went to Timmy's, I went to Tim Hortons to grab a drink because I wanted something cold to drink.
And then I saw that they had like Nutella.
I was like, ooh, Nutella, Nutella ice cap.
That sounds neat.
It's new.
I was like, Hmm, how come I haven't had Nutella in a very long time?
It's been years since I've had any Nutella, but people always talk about how great Nutella is.
I wonder why I haven't had Nutella in a long time.
And then I drank it, and I was just like, oh, that's... I remember, it's because I hate Nutella.
I took a sip, I was like, oh yeah, I fucking hate Nutella.
I don't... I didn't remember.
I didn't remember why I didn't like... I didn't remember that I hated Nutella.
I was just like, I wonder why I haven't drank Nutella in a long time.
I wonder why I haven't ate any Nutella-related stuff in a long time.
And I was like, oh yeah, it's because I don't like Nutella.
I never grew up with Nutella.
Because when Nutella became super popular, I guess in NA, I wasn't living in NA.
So it wasn't popular... Nutella wasn't that popular in Asia.
So the very first time...
I've had Nutella was when I was in high school.
So I just never grew up with a taste for Nutella.
It was just not for me.
I just remembered it.
I think I suppressed that memory for a long time.
And I just remembered it.
Taking that sip from the Nutella ice cap reminded me of how much I just never liked Nutella.
No, I'm not allergic.
The only thing I'm allergic to is strawberries.
So I'm not...
If I was allergic to nut, I would not be here right now.
I would be in the fucking hospital.
I would actually not show up if I was allergic to nuts.
Anyway, the reason why I don't like Nutella is just the nuttiness.
It's just really...
I thought it would be more chocolatey.
The nut flavor is just so overpowering.
And I'm not a huge fan of the taste.
I don't know.
I personally don't understand the appeal of Nutella in general.
But I think it's just because I never grew up with it.
So I never had the nostalgia of Nutella in general.
There's another type of food that I also never grew up with.
I'm trying to...
There's a childhood food a lot of people in NA really like.
But because I never grew up with that childhood food.
I've never liked it.
I'm trying to remember what it's called.
There's like this...
There's like a specific childhood food that a lot of people talk about how much they like it.
But I never liked it because...
Peanut butter!
I hate peanut butter.
Maybe I just don't like nuts.
I feel like...
I feel like there's a pattern.
I've never grew up with peanut butter.
Because first off, I'm Asian.
I feel like peanut butter is not an Asian thing.
But like...
I never...
I never grew up with peanut butter.
So like when I first tried peanut butter...
When I first tried peanut butter in like...
I think like almost high school.
I think like middle school.
I just didn't like it.
I just felt it was...
It's such a weird taste.
I guess it's just a nutty taste.
The nut taste in the...
In like...
I don't know.
It's just such a weird taste for me.
So like that's why I never liked peanut butter in general.
I tried crunchy peanut butter.
I tried cream peanut butter.
I tried smooth peanut butter.
I just don't like it.
I just...
Same with Nutella.
I just don't like it.
It's just not for me.
It's just...
It's not bitter.
It's just too nutty.
Like the...
I just don't like the taste of the nuts.
Like...
No matter what nut.
I don't like jam either.
I don't like jam that much as well.
Because like...
I guess if it's like...
Yeah.
I don't like jam as well.
Like a lot of these are just like stuff I never...
I never grew up with.
I never grew up with...
Yeah.
No.
Fuck.
I cannot.
I don't like Reese's cups.
I...
It's because it's peanut butter.
I could taste the peanut butter in Reese's...
Like Reese's cups.
So like it's just...
It's just not for me.
It's just...
It's such a weird like taste.
Like that my taste buds are not used to it at all.
So like...
I just...
I just can't like it at all.
I can't.
It's just...
It's just a very weird taste for my taste buds.
So like I could never get used to it at all.
Um...
I wanted to give a life update.
Oh yeah.
Welcome back Brazil.
Welcome back.
Uh...
I see that...
You know...
They ended up not banning Twitter.
So...
I like...
Welcome back.
I...
They...
Yeah.
They're like...
JK.
Uh...
Yeah.
They literally was like...
I remember I saw it on Twitter.
Like I...
I get all my news on Twitter by the way.
I don't know what's worse.
Me getting all my news on Twitter.
Or you guys getting all the news from me.
Who gets it from Twitter.
Uh...
But basically...
Brazil's back on Twitter guys.
Um...
They're...
The judge was like...
The judge and Ilan was like...
JK.
Uh...
We'll give you guys more time.
JK everybody.
It never happened.
That's the thing.
I don't think the...
I don't think like...
The ban actually happened.
I think they were just saying it.
And then like...
They just didn't do it.
It was like...
They were playing like chicken.
And...
Trying to see like who's gonna...
Who's gonna basically chicken out first.
But then like...
You know...
Uh...
Oh you still can't use it.
Oh!
Okay.
It ain't back yet.
Oh it's gonna come back soon.
Apparently.
Um...
Oh no it happened.
Wait it did?
What the fuck?
Wait what did I read?
Haha guys I can't believe you believe me.
Like...
Okay I can't believe you guys believe me.
What the fuck did I read?
Like...
What the fuck did...
Mis...
Spreading misinformation on the internet Doki?
How could you?
Wait what the fuck did I read?
I saw like a meme.
Guys.
I saw like a Brazil meme.
Like...
I saw a Brazil meme.
And I thought it was funny.
I was like whoa they're back?
Like...
I was like oh Brazil's back on Twitter.
It was a funny meme too.
It was a funny meme.
Haha.
Yeah.
Like they...
Cause it...
Cause it was a quote retweet from a news article.
So I was like oh that's funny.
Haha.
That's a funny meme.
It...
It quote retweeted an article.
Sorry Brazil.
You're not back by the way.
Um...
I take the welcome back.
And like...
Sorry Brazil.
You'll...
One day.
Haha.
Don't lose hope.
You'll be back soon Brazil.
Um...
Anyway.
Uh...
James.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's my birthday and I sent a super chat.
That means you have to sing.
Happy birthday.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear James.
Yeah!
To be fair, memes are the best form of news.
Cause like we live in a society now where...
Uh...
Which is pretty fucked.
Um...
Haha.
We...
We live in a society now that the only way a lot of us can process news if it's presented in a meme form.
And that...
That...
Like...
It...
Okay.
It's not sort of...
It's just pretty fucked.
My brain cannot comprehend real news anymore unless it's put...
Unless it's pasted onto a funny video.
Or like...
Onto a funny relatable video.
Or if it has like...
Um...
You know...
White text with black...
With black outlines.
Uh...
Under...
On top of a funny picture.
Uh...
I still follow the news?
Oh my god.
He's like the chosen one.
Like...
It's like...
It's basically like...
Nine...
Like...
Um...
Like this anti...
Uh...
This...
What was it called?
This hand sanitizer kills 99% of the bacteria.
You're like that 1% that's still alive.
Uh...
Or he's still alive.
He's just old.
Damn.
That's fucked guys.
That's really fucked.
Um...
Anyway.
Another news.
Um...
I've been practicing for Sajam Slam.
Like last night.
Um...
So...
Bad news.
Um...
Usually...
I play...
Um...
Usually...
I play like...
These fighting games.
Super late at night.
Like...
After I've done...
Everything.
Um...
After I've done everything.
Uh...
But...
The thing is...
Cause I'm very used to it.
I'm very used to just like...
Do grinding hours.
Um...
At like...
Dgen hour times.
Like...
After 10.
Um...
That's when I start playing.
Cause that's what I did for King.
For Tekken.
Um...
Apparently my coach is a normal human being.
Uh...
Like...
He has an actual...
Bedtime.
And he's a functioning member.
Of society.
Uh...
So...
I was told.
Not even from...
The coach...
Himself.
But like...
Bra Pro told me.
And he was like...
So...
Bad news.
Um...
His...
Office hours...
Are...
Ends...
At 10pm CST.
Which is...
8pm PST.
For me.
And I was like...
What the f...
I was like...
What do you mean?
8pm PST.
That's...
Like...
What the f...
Do you mean?
Like...
I'd still be streaming.
At those hours.
Um...
I was like...
Who the f...
Lives in C...
He lives in Central.
There's some people that actually live in Central, guys.
That's where the mountains are.
Um...
And...
So...
Like...
Uh...
So...
Right now...
Well...
Tomorrow is my first day.
So...
Maybe...
Uh...
Like...
Yeah...
Texas is the entire Central at this point.
Because Texas is the size of two f...
European countries.
Uh...
Anyway...
So...
This is our current solution.
Um...
Cause...
BrawlPro is main in GEEF as well.
So...
Like...
Brian...
Will be coaching BrawlPro.
And then...
I'm grabbing second hand knowledge from BrawlPro.
So...
Like...
He's just dumping the information to me.
As like...
Second hand.
Like...
It's not very ideal.
I would say.
It's not ideal at all.
Like...
Um...
But...
Like...
For now...
This is like...
Our current solution.
The hand me down education.
Yeah...
It's...
It's telephone coaching.
Cause...
At like...
5 in the morning...
Um...
During...
So...
I kept bumping into like...
J...
Like...
These 3 characters.
Jamie...
Ken...
And...
Julie.
I kept doing this...
Stupid ass move!
Called...
Apparently...
And I had to like...
Like...
And then I had to...
I was like...
I...
Like...
BrawlPro was still awake at 4 in the morning.
Thank fucking god.
Cause he's a degenerate.
Uh...
Like...
Degenerate.
Quote on quote.
Not negatively.
Hahaha!
Not in a negative way.
Bracket.
Um...
And...
It's called...
Like...
It's called a throw loop.
So...
Like...
Um...
So...
Like...
I was so fucking tilted.
Cause I kept getting...
This...
Mo...
Kept doing...
Getting...
Uh...
Sorry.
English.
My brain is not working right now.
Um...
Hahaha!
So...
They kept doing this thing called a...
Throw loop.
And it was fucking tilting me.
Cause I have no idea what it was.
And I lost so many rank points from it.
Because they realized...
I was just gonna spam throws all the time.
Like...
I wasn't doing any other moves.
I was just spamming throws.
By the way...
I'm almost silver rank.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
But like...
In...
In like...
5 hours...
I'm almost silver rank right now.
But like...
I literally don't know what I'm doing.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
Hahaha!
I had like...
At one point...
I think my longest win streak was like...
8 wins in a row.
I got 8...
Cause apparently the more wins you get...
The more rank points you earn.
So like...
Uh...
I instantly got from like...
Iron...
To like...
Uh...
I got passed through iron like...
Super fucking fast.
Um...
Because I got like...
8 wins in a row.
So like...
It like...
I was like...
It's like...
Plus 50...
Plus 100...
Plus 250...
Shit like that.
So the longer the win streak...
The more rank points you get.
So I got out of iron like...
Super fast.
Uh...
Um...
And so like...
I'm almost silver right now.
I got to bronze.
I'm like...
I think I'm like bronze...
4?
I think?
I'm bronze 4 at the moment.
So I need to be like...
I need like...
A star and a...
Like 2 more stars to be silver.
Um...
But I have no idea what I'm doing by the way.
Like...
All I did...
Was...
Spam throws.
As modern gif.
Like...
I don't know what's going on.
But...
I know how to counter those...
God damn...
Fucking...
Throw loops.
Cause...
That shit tilt...
I was so mad.
I was so...
Fucking mad.
Like...
And I kept...
And I was like...
Trying to figure out...
What that was.
Cause I was like...
What the fuck is that move?
Like...
What is that move?
And I was trying to look it up.
I was like...
I was trying to look it up on YouTube.
Cause I was like...
I don't have a coach right now.
So...
I was trying to...
I was looking up...
Looking up on it on YouTube.
And um...
And you know what I got on YouTube?
All I kept getting...
All I kept getting is like...
How to counter a gif.
How to get out of zangiefs grapples.
I'm like...
I played a zangief.
I'm getting grappled right now.
Like...
I don't get it.
I'm here!
I'm nearly- I'm the one that's getting gap rep!
I am the key!
I need to figure out how to get out of this!
Like, I don't understand!
So I was like, thank god.
I think like, BroadPro was like, in bed checking his phone or whatever.
Cause I was like, please, SOS.
I don't know what the fuck they're doing right now.
But I need you to tell me how to counter this.
Cause I cannot deal with this!
And then he like, literally- cause he was like, okay, what does it look like?
And I was like, I don't know, here's a recording.
And then he would have to like, okay, he's like, okay, I need to get on the game to figure this out too.
And so, yeah, so basically, I just need to do a normal grab back on him.
And back on those- I figured it out!
You know, he had to get back on Street Fighter.
Um, he had to get back on Street Fighter to like, teach me.
And I made him get back up at like, 4 in the morning.
To be fair, it was also 6 in the morning for him as well.
So I could get out of that throw loop!
Like, fuck the throw loop!
I'm supposed to loop you!
You're like, you're not supposed to loop me!
Like, how dare you!
I'm the grappler!
But yeah, I figured it out.
Um, you know what sucks?
Everybody is now purposely training to counter me.
Like, this is so fucked.
Like, it's me against the world!
It's literally me- people literally swap- swap their mains just to counter me!
It's so fucked up!
I'm just like, I'm not even good!
Like...
Like, I'm not even good at thi- It's because of my clip that went viral!
Like, the- the fucking clip also went- like, went viral in the FGC community!
So now all the new players, all the beginner players, are purposely training against me!
And I'm so mad!
Like...
I don't know what I'm doing!
Dayplay...
I...
Like, I don't understand!
Why is everyone training against me?
Oh my god...
Like, there's so many other new players!
Like...
There's like five other players!
But they're all training against Keef!
It just doesn't make sense!
Like...
Yeah, anyway...
Um...
They don't wanna be the next Akumi...
Sorry, I had to rat that out.
Cause I had- I had to- I had to, like, let that out real quick, by the way, guys.
Like...
I'm sorry we haven't started the game yet.
I know I was like- I was also, like, twenty minutes late.
And now, like, it's almost six p.m.
And I still haven't started the game.
Oh yeah.
Before...
Before- The crap I experienced!
Okay.
Before I start the stream- This game...
Um...
I wanna show you guys this comment I got.
Which I thought was the funniest- Like...
I-I-I don't even know, like, what they were trying to imply.
But, like...
I honestly thought it was, like, one of the funniest comments I got for Wukong.
But also, like...
Fuck you.
It was like...
What the fuck?
But also, fuck you.
Okay.
Um...
Alright.
I mean, I'm not gonna bother hiding the name.
Because it's literally, like, on my Wukong pod.
Like...
But, like, I'm gonna save this real fast.
Okay, I need to show you guys this.
Like...
I was like...
What does that- What are you trying to imply, bro?
Like...
Okay.
This is it.
Uh...
Oh, my God.
I have to say she is too weak.
I've seen many girls play Black Myth.
Their evasion and skills are good.
But Doki died five times just to fight a damn ice cream farm.
I have to say Doki's skill is too bad.
I don't know if it's- Bro, I fucking swear.
This bait.
Like, he did it.
He got- I got baited.
Um...
If this is engagement bait, he won.
Is she deliberately performing being abused by monsters increased the number of viewers?
Smile.
The passive-aggressive fucking smile.
He successfully engaged- Rage- Like, rage baited me.
Anyway, I just want to say- I just want to say- I fucking first tried so many bosses that were considered quote-unquote hard.
But the one time- I fucking struggled.
I fucking- Like, the fucking one time, I actually struggled.
They're like- Is she purposely performing bad just for more viewers?
Like, the fucking- Bro!
Oh no!
I wish I could first try more!
Oh my god.
Anyway, sorry.
Like, I got engagement baited.
So I had to like...
I had to show it.
They're waiting for reviews.
I fucking knew it.
I fucking knew she was better than...
Guys, honestly, if you guys think I'm actually like, if you guys really think I'm actually like, you know, performing worse for views, I'm really happy you think I'm actually really good at these video games.
Like...
I'm glad you guys think I'm...
I'm glad you guys think you have this vision of me being like a gaming savant.
That really helps my EO.
Like...
It really helps my EO.
Alright.
Let's play Wukong.
It's Wukong time.
Um...
Alright.
Into the land of bugs.
Here we go.
Alright.
We return to monkey.
It's monkey time.
Time to go for more viewers again.
How did he know?
How did he fucking know?
That's why I'm gamer of the year, guys.
Okay.
I guess we go this way.
Alright.
Off we go.
What?
Here?
I wanna explore first.
I don't know.
Should I explore or like...
Should I just go in now?
Just got exposed.
What?
You're gonna give me a key?
Oh?
Whoa!
Wait.
What?
Friend?
Wait.
What?
Friend?
Oh my god.
I'm big.
New form?
Oh!
Is that Pigsy?
Did he?
Did he transform?
Like, who the fuck is...
Is that... Is that JuBakGuy?
Yeah, I was gonna say, did he transform?
Yeah, I was like, what the...
Oh my god.
Am I wearing pants?
Oh, I'm not wearing pants.
I'm not.
We're both not wearing pants.
Oh!
Oh, it was a trap!
What?
Woman?
How did you two come this late?
Your wife didn't come again this time?
Uh, my wife is short in status.
It's inconvenient for her to show up in the next world.
But in her heart, she always cares about you guys.
My wife told me.
I hope my daughter recovers soon.
I hope she can go to heaven soon.
Oh, Zoom subs.
I thought I had it on.
Sorry, guys.
Hahaha.
And now...
Li was stolen.
Ren was killed.
How about...
What?
What did I do?
I'm just a monkey.
A pig.
I'm just a piggy.
I know I'm lagging on the casino.
How did you know?
I'm just a piggy.
I'm a pig.
I don't know.
No.
You have to be more specific.
He ruined a lot of ladies' lives.
He's fucked over a lot of people.
You have to be more specific.
He's fucked over a lot of ladies' lives.
And this is the first sentence.
All right.
Big attack time.
Oh, yeah.
I don't know how I feel about this spider.
Please, please help me.
This is your problem.
This is your issue.
Like, why am I involved in your family problems?
It's all right, guys.
Even if we kill her, it's fine.
Like, I don't know if you guys know this, but spiders have a lot of babies.
So, I don't think that mom would care, you know?
Like, I mean, I don't think she'll remember.
Why is it my issue?
I'm literally... I'm the tourist.
I'm just sightseeing.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
All right.
Guys, you know, like... No, this is absolutely... At least grounded, you can, like, turn on...
You can turn on, like... What was it called?
Arachnophobia?
So, they look like boxes, but you can't do that for this game.
All right.
What's his name?
What was his name again?
What was your name?
All right, darling.
Fucking first try.
That's right.
A fucking first try.
Fucking ice cream frog.
No, Doki.
You're killing her too... Killing them too fast.
How else are you gonna get the views?
Doki will remember that.
What if he just likes hanging out with monkeys?
Yes, he clearly has a preference.
Spiders and monkeys.
I'm not scared.
Jesus.
What did you do?
Oh, my God.
What did you do in this area, Chewbacca?
Like, why do you hold such a huge grudge against... I mean, to be fair, like, spiders...
They're spiders, so...
Spider lives do not matter.
Yes, I know they're very good for the environment, but I will never change my opinion.
I...
As long as they are not near me, I don't mind.
If they're not near me, they live.
To be fair, I won't be the one killing them.
It would be, like, somebody...
They would just...
You know what?
No, I don't know why I'm being so cocky about that.
Because if I see a spider in my room, it's their room now.
Like, it's not even my room anymore.
Like, I once, like...
I remember, like, when I used to live in Asia, there was a spider in the bathroom.
And then I...
And then I just used my parents' bathroom.
I used my parents' bathroom for, like, two plus weeks until, like...
Until it was safe to go back in.
Because in my head, I was like, it must have starved to death by now.
Alright, let's see.
Let's take a sip.
I'm gonna look at the graphics, because I don't know why I'm lagging during cutscenes.
Every day.
Every day there's something new.
And I know...
Every day there's just something new here.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Just gotta deal with the newest...
The newest thing in the world.
It's just like me.
Alright, here we go.
The crash of 64.
Ever since the crash of 64, nothing has been the same since...
Oh hey, nice.
Ooh, materials.
Okay, but I...
I don't like playing with 60 frames.
It's...
Oh yeah, I should use this.
Means for a short time after casting a spell...
Let me charge up to 4 within...
Wait, I should get this.
Modern Extended Dodge Env...
Yeah, wait.
That's good.
Hold breath.
I can't.
I tried it for like 2 seconds and I can't.
I can't do this.
I'm not strong enough, I'm sorry.
I'm not strong enough.
I couldn't.
I tried.
Like 2 seconds.
And I had...
I won't...
My body had like a negative reaction to it.
Like...
Doki.
No shadows?
Okay, we'll do low.
Maybe this will fix it.
Maybe this will fix everything.
Okay.
I...
No, I would.
I would...
I would rather die.
It's...
It's not even like...
It's not...
It's just my body would actually shut down.
I would...
Like...
If I play a game with too low frames, my body would actually shut down.
I cannot handle that.
Like my organs will start to fail.
It just cannot look at something that has less than 60 frames.
Or that has less than 100 frames.
No, it won't.
How would you know that?
You don't know my body.
Okay, let's see.
Is this stronger?
Oh, it's stronger!
Gold Tree Core?
How the fuck do I get a Gold Tree Core?
Okay.
Oh, wait!
I could craft this right now.
80%.
108?
Holy fuck.
Okay, I'm gonna grab this first.
Um, because it's 80 anyway.
Wait, am I...
Okay.
I have the Ice Staff, so...
Wait, what do I have?
I have 75.
Okay.
I am going to grab...
I'll grab this one.
Yes, I'm allergic.
I am...
I have a doctor's note that tells people that I am severely allergic to 100 frames per second.
That anything that's less than 100 frames per second, I will have a very bad allergic reaction.
It's just...
I was just born that way, sadly.
When the doctors were like, it's incurable.
It's so sad.
Even the doctors were like, there's nothing we can do about it.
She has to live with this curse.
For the rest of her life.
You think...
You think I want to live like this?
You really th- This is not... I did consent to live like this.
Oh my god, there's too many bugs!
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Okay.
Jesus Christ, these guys are so annoying!
Oh shit, okay.
No, please don't let me die to a mob.
Please don't let me die to a mob.
Bugs for days.
Oh my god, I hate that they swarm.
I hate it.
It's so fucking annoying.
Alright, I don't know where to... I feel like there's stuff I missed.
There's so many things around me.
Wait, what the fuck is that?
Oh, it's a spider.
Oh, they're baby spiders!
Oh, that is a lot.
I got baited.
I got baited!
Okay.
How are you so strong?
You're just babies!
Oh, it's because they're rock babies!
Okay.
I got baited so fucking hard there.
Alright.
Absorb.
I have no more... I have no more items anymore.
I swear to god!
Right after!
That's fucked.
I can't believe it.
Not only were there babies, but there's also fungus, too.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Easy.
Wait, did I get poisoned?
God fucking dammit.
Okay, that's fine.
I'm going back because I know I missed some items and stuff.
Back here.
Alright, off we go.
I hope the...
Yeah, I haven't been here before.
Oh, yeah, I definitely have not been here.
Okay, this is like...
Okay, I might have fucked up a little bit.
Me here.
This is... this is pretty bad.
This is... oh, this is very bad.
This is... this is very bad.
Alright, I'll come back here soon.
Oh, and now I'm in the water.
Hello, guys.
Hey, everybody.
Oh, oh, and they're gonna try and chase me.
Okay.
Alright.
Instant transmission.
Oh, am I in a fight?
Oh, I'm in a fight.
You can't instant transmission when you're on a fight.
Did you guys know that?
I'm gonna take this, though, real quick.
Is he still following me?
That'll be very awkward.
Oh, he's not.
Okay.
Instant transmission.
Sorry, I dropped into somebody else's house.
Alright.
I wish this did have the arachnophobia... the arachnophobia option.
Because I want to know what it would look like, you know?
I just want to know what it would look like.
Because they're always so silly.
Like, if this entire chapter was just, like, boxes or something.
No, I just think it looks really funny.
That's really it.
For the content.
I just want to know what they would... what they would turn into.
But we gave them arachnophobia option.
Alright.
Asia doesn't care about arachnophobia.
To be fair, like...
There's a...
Oh my god.
Okay, let me...
Let me get rid of this.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
To be fair, if you have arachnophobia...
And you live in Asia...
Like, sucks to be you, I guess.
Like, there's no avoiding that shit.
Not gonna lie.
Like, mosquitoes alone...
Is, like, a problem.
I remember when...
I remember when I would watch, like, TVV.
And I would swear.
They would play the fucking mosquito.
The mosquito PSA.
That was made 20...
30 years ago.
I don't know if they still play it.
But, like, when I used to watch TVV back in, like, Asia...
Um, they would play this mosquito PSA.
Like, they would play two...
Three different mosquito PSAs.
And, um...
And, like...
It was...
It was filmed, like, 30 plus years ago.
And they still...
And they play it non-stop.
It's like...
Every 10 minutes...
They always play the mosquito PSA.
Because mosquitoes are a huge problem.
Like...
It's a fucking huge problem.
It's like something about, like...
Oh, remember to, like, change the water underneath the plants.
Or so the mosquitoes can't lay their eggs.
Like...
I don't know where I've been and where I haven't been.
It's not really that big of, like, a place, too.
That's the thing.
Wait.
It's here.
Okay.
It's over here.
Oh.
All right.
I'm just gonna run.
I really don't want to deal...
These guys are really annoying to fight.
I don't want to deal with them.
Go west.
Right.
No.
Left.
Wait.
No.
West Coast is on the left.
Guys, I know my left and right.
Guys, I know my left and right, guys.
Okay.
Doki, please throw more.
We need more people to watch.
Okay.
All right.
I know!
West Coast is left.
North is up.
South is down.
And East is right.
I know I'm west.
I live in the West Coast.
So I'm on the left side of the world.
That's how I know.
Because West Coast is on the left.
Wait.
Am I allowed to go down here?
Oh.
Okay.
Thank God.
I have zero survival instinct.
Okay.
I have no survival instinct.
This hole looks very dangerous.
Maybe I should jump down.
Oh, maybe I should not have jumped down.
Did I die?
Oh, no.
I'm just Kukun.
I'm just going to get digested with the spider acid.
They got me a bed.
That's nice of them.
All right.
You're making sure, like, I feel welcome.
I'm not lagging as much anymore, at least, during cutscenes, I think.
I can't tell anymore.
The crash at 24 really fucked up my PC.
Alright, up here, there's a... I wanna grab the...
I wanna grab this first before I go anywhere.
That's how spider monkeys are born.
When a mama spider and a papa monkey love each other very, very much.
Okay, no, maybe it should be the other way around.
Maybe it should be the other...
When a mama monkey and a spider...
Papa love each other very much.
They make a spider monkey.
How it works...
Well, how do you say...
How do you think they get chihuahua mixed breeds?
Okay, let me show you guys.
I always wonder about this.
Okay, chihuahua...
mixed breeds.
I don't know if you ever...
Guys, I always wonder how the fuck were they able to make these chihuahua.
Like, how did they cross a chihuahua and a fucking terrier?
Like, what...
Dude, oh my gosh.
It's like...
They're such big dogs.
And I'm like, how did you get a chihuahua?
To like...
Like, how does that work?
I'll never understand.
Like, I don't...
I sort of...
I don't want to also.
Turkey, no, please.
Alright, here, let me...
Okay, so, let me show you a mixed breed.
I saw one that was like...
How the fuck...
I remember seeing one of the mixed breeds.
And I'm just like...
How?
Like, oh!
Okay, a shib...
A shib-chi.
So, they crossed a shiba inu with a chihuahua.
And we all know how...
I'm just like thinking, like...
Which one's the mom and which one's the dad?
Like...
Like, look...
It's...
I guess, like, he's cute.
But it's like...
It's like...
Which...
He's pretty huge.
Like, do you guys...
Okay, alright.
Let me give you a size comparison.
And...
A chihuahua.
Turkey, why do you not stop?
So...
So, you guys all know how big a...
Like, a shi...
Okay...
Shiba inu is...
Shiba inu is compared to a chihuahua.
Chihuahua is like one-third...
What?
Not even one-third!
It's like one fourth a size.
So, I'm just like, how?
How does this?
How?
Oh my God!
There's a Chihuahua German Shepherd?
Another mix that seems... How?
It doesn't even look like a Chihuahua at that point.
Like, how the fuck is... Who's the mom?
Like, oh my God!
This is a Chihuahua mix of a German... Okay.
A German Shepherd next to a Chihu...
I think... Stop contemplating this.
Alright, guys.
Okay, this is the last thing.
This is the last thing I'll send you.
This is the last... I swear.
This is the last one, guys.
I swear.
Wait, there's a sock photo of this to visualize this better.
This is the size comparison between a...
So, this is a German Shepherd next to a Chihuahua.
Just so you guys have, like, a proper visualization.
Of, like...
Who is the mom?
Who could be the mom?
Who... Which one's the mom and which one's the...
This is a better comparison.
Which...
Which one's the mom and which one's the dad?
Like, so...
There's a Chihuahua Rottweiler?
A Chih-whaler?
Oh my God!
The Chih-whaler isn't as common as other Chihuahua mixes.
But there's certain...
Oh, I wonder why.
I wonder why Chihuahua and Rottweilers are not a common...
Not a common Chihuahua mix.
I wonder why.
Okay, that is actually worse than the German Shepherd.
That is...
So you're saying skinny...
Alright, here's a...
Alright, here's another...
Okay, this is the last visualization.
Thank you, Stock Photos, for putting, like, dog...
Chihuahuas next to other dog breeds.
I really appreciate it for the visualization.
I...
Who started it?
Who was the one that talked about spider monkeys and, like, how does it work?
That's on them.
Thank that, Dragoon.
Uh, Frank...
We...
Okay, here we go.
No, I didn't start it!
I didn't start it!
You guys questioned it!
You guys fucking questioned it!
So this is, like, a Chihuahua next to a Rottweiler.
So, like, don't ever say, like, how does a spider and a monkey...
Get it going.
When we have Rottweiler-Chihuahua mixes.
In the world.
Uh...
I can't believe we got calendar.
Alright.
Let's see.
Let's see, where do I go?
There's so many places I could go.
But which way is the right way?
I'll just go to the right side.
It was finally how people started calling out random...
Random Dragoons.
Like, it was you, wasn't it?
Alright, let's get this guy out of here.
Oh, shit.
He's so fast.
He's so...
It's alright.
Spider-Mama can just give birth to another.
Glory to Spider-Mama.
Oh yeah, I should actually upgrade.
I keep forgetting to upgrade stuff, dude.
Alright, let's get all this spellbinding shit.
Might as well.
Alright.
I don't need other...
I don't...
I don't need anything else.
Okay.
Father, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What do you call a Bulldog and a Shih Tzu mix?
I don't know.
What do you call that?
Is this a joke or are you actually curious?
I can't tell.
I don't know if you're using me as a form of Google.
Or like if you...
It's a joke.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Father.
Oh, bullshit!
Nice.
That was...
Actually...
I'm sorry.
What's the joke?
So you can super chat me the joke.
I'm joking.
Guys, I'm...
Oh my God.
What is it?
The only way I know is if you super chat me the answer.
Finally.
No, no.
I...
What?
What is it?
What kind of mix would it be?
Okay.
Oh, what?
I got a spine?
Which spine is this?
Oh, shit.
Wait, you're still alive?
Oh, oh.
Oh, no.
No.
It's all right.
We're fine.
Fine.
Guys, if you know the answer, make sure to super chat it so I can see it.
For legal reasons, that's a joke.
Okay.
In before Doki Birds gets canceled for she begs for...
She baits her viewers for money.
Okay.
All right.
She's not joking.
Nice.
Drop the answer in the comment below, but she'll only be able to read it if...
It's like...
Oh man, it's so unfortunate that like I'm color... I'm colorblind and I could only read messages that are in red.
It's so unfortunate.
I have a special type of colorblindness.
I can't read any text that's not behind a red background.
I see.
That's crazy.
It's so unfortunate.
I know it's a curse.
I was born with...
With this sickness.
I'm just raising awareness, you know, I'm just here raising awareness.
It's so painful to live with it every day of my life.
I was born with so many debuffs.
It's just very unlucky.
All right, nice.
Easy.
Oh, but not easy.
Oh my god, wait, Burrito said something?
What?
Did you...
Wait, what did he say?
I gotta get rid of him.
Jeez, this... this area is like so annoying though, because they like swarmed you so... they like swarmed you so much.
Did I go the right way?
I feel like this is like a maze.
There's so many like tunnels and everything.
Do I go down?
Oh, I do.
Okay, I only have like one heal left.
Let's see.
Where else do I go?
I guess down?
Oh, nice.
There's an... oh no, not nice.
Okay, let me heal this and then get the spellbinder real fast.
Look, I can see the spellbinder because it's right...
Oh my god, guys!
I can see the spellbinder!
I can actually see my staff now!
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but it was so hard to see my staff.
But now that it's red, I can finally see what I'm... what I'm holding onto.
God, I'm so lucky.
I'm dead.
There's no way.
I'm so fucking dead.
I am so dead.
No!
Oh!
Paint used to be blue!
Unbelievable.
Anyway, Burrito, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, it's because one is a bulldog and the other is a Shih Tzu.
So the cross would clearly be a zoo dog.
Oh yeah!
You're right!
It's a zoo dog!
Oh, that's so funny.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, this way.
This way.
I'm just gonna run past all of these.
These monsters are so annoying to fight.
Like, I cannot be bothered.
She's throwing for...
God, Doki, what happened to you?
You've changed.
Why are you throwing for money and engagement?
You could have easily killed these guys, Doki.
Now you're dying to mobs?
What the fuck happened to you?
Guys, it's because they're not red.
Like, I told you guys, I can't see anything that's not red anymore.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, wait, you followed me?
Oh, shit!
It's awkward.
Because that one guy told me that if I suck more, more people...
If I die...
If I die more, I'll get more viewers.
Apparently.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, where the fuck am I?
This is, like, new area.
Oh, I feel like I should not have gone this way.
This way feels, like, more dangerous.
Yeah, I went the danger area.
The one I went before seems a lot safer.
Yeah, it definitely feels a lot safer.
Yeah, now there's a scorpion guy, too.
Like, I...
Oh, yeah, this area does not feel safe.
I do not feel safe at all.
Oh, there's so many things here.
Oh!
There are so many things here.
Oh, and I missed.
What happened to Pigsy?
I don't even know what happened to him.
Like, am I...
I definitely went the more dangerous.
I wonder if, like, these guys...
Okay.
I'm just gonna get rid of them first.
Oh, fuck, okay.
I'm just gonna get rid of these guys first.
What the fuck?
How did I get here?
Oh, it's cause my...
What the fuck?
Okay!
Okay, this is actual bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
Wait, where am I?
Where am I?
Like...
This...
How is it...
How is there more of a maze?
I already went through all the maze area!
Oh no.
Oh my god...
Oh my god, this is so frustrating.
This is actually so frustrating.
Okay, let's just meditate.
And clear our heads.
You know, to be fair...
With all these debuffs...
I'm a pretty good gamer being able to see through...
Only being able to see through the color red.
I'm practically playing by sound alone.
Okay, at least we have the meditation center.
To cool things down.
Yeah, I use echolocation to figure out where to go.
Oh, thank god there is an incense here.
Go, go!
Where do I go next?
Alright, nice.
Oh yeah, you're right.
Sorry, I just screeched for no reason.
I actually use my laugh to echolocate.
That's why I laugh all the time.
I know everything makes so much more sense now.
Oh wait, do they not come out?
Are they just there?
Oh, ew!
What the fuck?
Oh, that's gross.
That's actually gross.
Laughing is actually my echolocation.
Oh lord, drop.
Alright, I'm trying...
Alright, where am I?
Alright, I gotta figure out...
Where do I go next?
Okay, so I have to go this way.
Alright, now I have to go left.
Alright.
Okay.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, it's just a cocoon.
Like, is anything gonna happen?
Nothing?
Does anybody live here?
Why is this a boss?
Oh.
I don't think he liked that.
Ugh!
Wait.
I can't see where you are.
Okay, there you are.
I'm trying to figure out where he is.
I'm echolocating right now, guys.
Just so you guys know.
You know, I'm trying to echolocate.
Okay, he's right over here.
It's working!
It's working guys!
I figured out where he is!
Laughing daredevil.
Oh my god, I told you guys!
Coincidence?
That's why I laugh so much!
Whoa!
Sorry, I forgot to laugh, so that's how he got me.
Every time he hits me.
Guys!
Every time he hits me, I forgot to laugh!
Wait, what?
How did you lose so much HP?
Oh, it's because he's just a baby!
I literally beat up a baby there.
He just got born.
It actually worked!
Doki, you were supposed to lose to him!
Now you're not going to get the viewership!
Laughing daredevil.
I don't even know if I was going the right area.
Like, I'm so fucking lost.
Return.
I think he has to be like a bonus boss, because there should be a bonus boss.
There's nowhere else to go here.
Yeah, you know, I forced him to be given birth.
He would have been stuck in the womb his entire life.
If it wasn't for me.
Like, was he optional?
I don't like this area.
I really don't like this area.
Holy fuck.
Laughing.
Alright.
Hey, I didn't lose to a baby!
I didn't lose to a baby!
He's for the secret area?
Alright.
Did I unlock it?
Did I do it?
I don't even know.
Did I just somehow stumble into a secret area?
Like, what the fuck?
I'm so lost.
Laughing.
I'm so fucking lost.
I just somehow stumbled into the secret area.
Oh, this is an XP.
Oh, I might as well kill these.
For XP.
Like, they're here anyway.
Laughing.
I need the money.
Alright.
Laughing.
Woo!
How much does it give?
I mean, 105 ain't too bad.
Laughing.
Woo!
It's convenient that I can just...
You know.
I don't have to be close.
I just can farm these.
Guys, we need the money, guys.
We need like 40k apparently.
Laughing.
We're broke right now.
We gotta tap those stacks.
Laughing.
Woo!
Okay, another tap.
Oh, and he gave me gold too!
Laughing.
Nice.
Tap.
I feel like I don't really need XP that much.
I feel like if I overlevel it's not gonna be...
Like...
I'm gonna lose even more viewers.
Laughing.
Because of how good I am!
Guys, if I overlevel...
I'm gonna lose my viewership.
Laughing.
Tap that.
Jesus Christ, it's just everywhere.
Too strong unsubscribe.
Laughing.
I'm not here to watch VTubers be competent at video games.
You gotta start throwing to be safe.
You're right.
You're so right, guys.
Laughing.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
Do they just not move?
Oh, they're just...
Oh, wait.
I don't even have to tap them.
They literally are just there to get farmed.
Laughing.
Hey.
They're literally... look.
They're literally just there to get farmed.
They haven't been like...
fully developed yet.
Good.
Laughing.
So I'll feel less bad.
Hey.
Let's see.
Where do I go?
Oh...
I guess I go down?
Okay, no I do not go down.
Hey, what?
Then where do I go?
I feel like I've been everywhere.
Wait.
Can I meditate again?
I can meditate again?
What?
Can I get the...
level?
Oh, no?
Oh, I don't get anything?
What's the point of meditating?
Laughing.
That's so Buddha of you, Dokie.
What's the point of meditating if I don't get anything in return?
Laughing.
Who needs inner peace?
Inner peace doesn't give me money.
I don't need no inner peace.
I'm very sad of you.
What's inner peace?
Can I monetize that?
Do I get stronger?
Naturally true.
Alright, let's see.
Where the fuck do I go from here?
It raises my inner monkey.
Oh, there's a stair here.
Okay, there's staircases here.
There's a platform, which is good.
Inner peace don't pay no bill.
We're not bad people, I swear.
Okay.
I guess we go here.
Whoa!
What are you doing here?
Get out of here.
You don't belong.
You're not a spider.
Spiders only.
This is for spiders and monkeys.
And also pigs.
And also beetles.
But anything that flies...
Anything that flies is a no-go.
I guess we go this way.
And centipedes.
But not you.
You have wings.
You're bad.
And scorpions too.
Yeah, and scorpions.
This is a no-fly zone, exactly.
You get it.
Nobody is allowed to fly.
Did I come from here?
Yeah, this is a scorpion.
Wait, then where do I go from here?
Here?
Oh, okay, there you go.
There's a platform.
I might as well grab this.
And then another platform.
Now where am I?
And then I guess this way?
Is this platform?
Oh, there he is!
There's the beetle.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready this time.
Wait, where's the fly with the bow?
Okay, we gotta get rid of him first though.
This guy is a problem.
Alright, nice.
Alright, now we're fine.
Wait, you have wings.
That's not allowed.
This is a no-fly zone?
Sir?
Sir, this is a no-fly zone.
I don't make the rules.
You're not allowed to fly here.
Oh, shit.
Okay, we both hit each other.
That's good.
Alright.
Nice.
We finally got this area.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Lord question, can Doki fly or just Kroki?
Like, can you just levitate?
Can you just levitate at some time?
That's a good question.
Alright, where should I go after this?
I guess I go this way.
I never know where to go.
Come on.
Whoa!
Okay, nice.
I dodged it.
Wait, I can kill these egg sacs for extra money?
Wait, nice.
I didn't know that.
Oh, they're like jars.
Kroki is like my private jet.
Time to go to the grocery store.
Let me grab this private jet real quick.
Okay.
Get these rocks out.
Get these spider rocks.
Coke!
Oh, the rice cocoons are for a quest.
Do not sell them.
Oh, the ones I'm holding onto?
Whoa!
I was just curious about this mushroom.
This funky mushroom.
Alright, nice.
Gather time.
Esa, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Welcome!
I love it.
I'll level up later.
I need to get rid of this guy.
He's in the no-fly zone.
Get out of here.
This is the no-fly zone.
Okay, let me heal too, just in case.
Now where am I?
Everything looks the same.
It's just rocks.
Where am I?
Will I ever know where I am?
Find out next time on the next episode of Dokian Bug Country.
Just rocks and webs.
Okay, nice.
I should be able to kill him without him being able to do anything.
Do I get to hit these?
Oh, hey!
This is a secret area!
I fucking knew it.
Alright.
Coke!
Nice.
Oh, combo!
A Collat!
It's got Collat!
Nice.
Nice Collat.
Oh shit.
Wait, that's a bigger one.
Wait, that's a huge one.
No country for old bugs.
Alright.
Nice another Collat.
This should be the last one.
Wombo combo!
You get like five, like a hundred each, which is pretty nice.
For like something that doesn't move.
Is it this?
Are you the bad one?
No.
Okay.
What the fuck is that?
The fuck?
Can it even move?
Oh, it can't even move.
Oh shit.
Oh, what?
How strong are you?
Holy shit!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, okay.
Are you blue?
Oh, he's blue!
Oh, that makes more sense.
You're blue.
Alright, nice.
Now let me absorb you.
Alright.
Another item I'll never use.
I was like, how the fuck did he take 80% of my HP?
I was able to squish all of them.
These guys don't...
Oh.
Oh, he's just a little worm.
Bye.
Did I do something bad?
Oh, he's not a little worm!
No more!
Is he gonna slam?
What's he gonna do?
He's just a little worm.
Guys, he's...
he's not so little anymore.
Yes.
Nevermind.
He's not just a little worm.
Oh!
Here you go.
I hate these.
I hate...
I hate all the Guai's in this.
I don't like any of the guise in this chapter.
It's so gross.
I hate bugs so much.
Wait, is that it?
Is that it?
Is there nothing else?
Yeah, this whole area is pretty gross.
Is there anything I should be getting from here or what?
There should be a room with treasures.
Go back to the shrine behind.
Guys, where's the shrine?
I don't even know where I came from.
Where did I come from?
Where's the shrine?
I'll get rid of this.
Yeah, but I used the teleporter to fight all of them again.
We don't like that.
We don't want to fight them.
Can I go up this way?
Guys, I can't go up this way, okay?
Fine, I'll use the teleporter.
Instant transmission.
Alright.
There's apparently a treasure behind this shrine.
This way?
What is considered behind?
Guys, is it this way?
Where did I come from?
It's here?
No, it's to the left?
This is the left.
My left?
This is where I came from.
Did I jump down from here?
The opposite from the front?
To your west.
Oh, west!
That's this way!
My other left?
Oh, it's this way!
Guys, I...
I don't know which left it is.
Over green bridge and then left.
Oh, oh it's this way.
So I was right.
Okay, this way.
Right?
Is this where treasure is at?
Who's fighting?
What does that mean?
I'll always be last.
Please!
Stop!
Okay, give me a sec!
The voices!
Oh, it's the lanterns!
Oh, thank god.
Even Wukong was like, shut the fuck up.
He's like, I can't take it anymore.
I can't take it.
Wukongquxui son.
And he was like, STOP!
STOP THE VOICES!!!
He couldn't handle it either.
Alright, absorb.
Of course, there's so many hot ladies!
They all came from a very hot mom!
Hot mom spider!
Okay.
Right?
Spotters can give birth to a lot of hot ladies.
Hot spotter ladies.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, there's treasure.
This is totally a trap.
Wow, there's so many treasures here.
I wonder what's gonna happen when I open all of them up.
Wow, all these treasures lying there.
All defenseless and vulnerable.
It would be a shame if a monkey comes over and just takes them.
Wait, nothing happened?
Nothing happened?
Oh my gosh, she likes me.
Wait a minute, guys.
Guys, I think she likes me.
What's that?
She's just chilling there.
Oh my god.
Nothing happened?
I'm not...
I don't know what I expected.
I was like, ooh.
This big worm baby thing.
Sure looks so...
Sure looks innocent.
And it's gonna be...
helping me.
He doesn't look dangerous at all.
Damn.
I wonder what this worm thing is doing here.
Oh my god, he has a face.
What the fuck?
I like how he...
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
He has to get closer, right?
Oh, I'm getting policed.
Never mind.
Hahaha.
If you don't do that.
Oh!
Okay, that's gross.
That is very gross.
Sir, please.
Please wear a diaper, sir.
Juices should not be flowing all willy-nilly.
Oh, nice.
I got the proto-armor worm.
I don't know why I just jumped in there.
Like, haha.
It's like...
My gosh.
Golly gee williker.
That worm sure do look awfully friendly.
Just lying there.
Alright, nice.
Is that it?
Go back to the shrine and talk to the dragon guy?
There's a dragon guy?
Which...
There's a dragon...
Alright.
Let me heal.
Too fast again.
Doki, we're missing all the new viewers.
How are you first trying all the bosses, Doki?
Oh, the grandpa?
Oh, it's your instant transmission then.
I'm gonna go to the art world.
Tythus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, would you still love us if we were a worm?
I told you guys about that funny...
This is a really funny tweet I saw.
It was basically like this girl tweeted about like how she broke up with her ex-boyfriend.
Because she said like, oh, would you love me if I was still a worm?
And then he was like, no, but I'll get you a really nice terranium.
So like, you can like live your life in there really happy and spoiled.
And you can see who I'm dating next.
And then I was like...
And then they got into a really big argument and she broke up with him.
Haha!
Alright.
Oh, I'm here to deliver the worm.
I'll cook my habit.
I thought he was friend and then he tried to spit on me.
Oooh, he's gonna study.
Alright, we're gonna look at the dragon.
I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
What did I miss?
Nothing?
Okay, that's good.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright, let's grab all these materials.
I'll harvest everything.
I'm not gonna use it, but I'll harvest all of it.
Alright.
Alright, let's grab some...
Oh, wait.
Oh, you have upgrade?
Do you have any upgrades?
I do!
Okay, nice.
Upgrade!
I love upgrades.
Uh...
Oh, do I have new soaks?
Uses the gourd...
Increases health recovery from using the gourd when at critical health.
Wait, what do I have?
I have...
Oh, okay.
I don't need that.
Okay, I can just use...
I'll just use that.
I'm not using Cloud Strike anymore, anyway.
Scatter!
Near the harvest area?
Give you rest?
Okay.
That's fast.
Alright, rest time.
Alright.
Worm, worm, worm!
Do you have something for me, old dragon?
No, I don't.
You fucking lies.
Worms... Worms don't...
Wait, how do worms reproduce?
How do worms reproduce?
Do they do it the same way?
The male cell in each worm then fertilize the female cells on...
Oh, okay.
Two mature worms lie next to each other, head to tail.
Oh!
Oh, that's interesting.
Oh, that's how they do it?
What the fuck?
Guys, science lesson with Doki.
Do you guys wanna know how worms...
I wanna know how...
Do worms lay eggs?
Wait, are there worm eggs?
How...
How do worms make lay...
Lay eggs?
Have you guys never been curious?
I'm just curious!
They just always like snakes when they like...
When they like tangle...
They like wrestle, you know?
So you see two snakes like wrestling each other.
Oh, they're not wrestling.
They're not wrestling.
Quick YouTube pattern now!
The worms are holding hands, quote on quote.
It's free education!
I'm just...
Oh my God!
What the fuck is that?
What!
What the fuck is...
Do you guys wanna see what worms look like with baby worms?
Worms?
What the fuck?
Maybe I should show this on YouTube.
I'm not gonna show this.
Bro!
What the fuck are these eggs?
What are these?
Oh my god!
Okay.
Today I learned.
Guys, don't look at worm eggs.
Don't look at worm eggs.
I'm eating dinner.
Don't look up worm eggs.
You guys don't wanna know.
Alright.
Cause I never seen like worms, baby worms before.
Like hatching and stuff like that.
So I got curious.
Where did that come from?
Here?
When does the worm give birth?
When does the worm...
Thasm.
You coward!
Sad face.
I mean, if my mod wants to link it...
If my mod wants to link it...
Okay I know about the echidna thing.
I think that's like everybody knows about it because of the Knuckles comic.
Where I have to go next?
This science fact brought to you This science fact brought to you by bacon and eggs.
By bacon and eggs.
Now that the- now that your stream is demonetized, here is your ad revenue replacement.
Thank you for the super chat, Papa Sprint.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, nice.
I mean, not nice.
I don't wanna get demonetized.
Oh, what Knuckles comic?
You don't wanna know.
It's okay, you don't wanna know, guys.
You don't- if you guys don't know about the Knuckles comic, then, like, that good- Your life on the internet was maybe a lot better than mine.
You had a more wholesome- wholesome history with the internet.
What's that green thing?
What fucking debuff do I have?
Is that poison?
Oh, I guess that's poison.
They're too pure for this.
Guys, I- You guys have to remember, I grew up on Newgrounds.
A lot of things came from Newgrounds.
Newgrounds basically shaped my childhood.
I guess I wanna get more of this, then.
I'll get the basic upgrades.
Cannot awaken, it's because of this?
Reduce the stamina of jump.
Grants a considerable amount of damage reduction.
Oh, okay.
Get that.
And then...
Oh, it explodes?
It goes bang?
Guys, I did not play the meat and fuck games.
I- I was not on that side of Newgrounds.
I just need you guys to know.
I was- I say I'm a Newgrounds- I- I would admit I was not that type of Newgrounds kid.
I- There's two Newgrounds kid.
Is that and then- And then the edgy ones.
Of course I know about them.
Everybody on Newgrounds know about them.
It was there.
Of course I know about them.
I lied about my age on the internet.
So I would see it on the trending pages.
All right.
Nice Wait, what the fuck?
Where did these guys come from?
Yeah.
Thank you.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome.
Let's see...
Goodbye.
Oh shit.
Sorry, man.
No, he- How could you do this?
He was just trying to do his job.
He was just providing light.
Hahaha.
He's just providing light to the citizens!
Okay, let's see.
I guess I go this way, right?
Toki, you can just lie on the internet.
What if I'll just... I mean, I could just use the baby.
I haven't used Big Baby in a long time.
Wait, oh!
Big Baby doesn't work!
Wait a second!
I didn't know Big Baby is also magic!
Oh shit!
Okay.
I just saw Big Baby as his own thing!
Big Baby was just Big Baby!
How the fuck was Big Baby not just Big Baby?!
Big Baby is now sealed.
Okay, let's see if I can get him from here.
Nice.
What the fuck?!
Okay!
I am here now!
Okay.
It said magic?
Big Baby is magic!
He's in magic?
He's just a part of me!
We all have a big baby inside of us.
Oh yeah, Mint was the one that played those, not me.
Okay.
I saw that too.
Alright.
Oh shit!
Okay, I need heal.
Okay, nice.
Get out.
Get out!
Oh!
Oh no!
Alright.
It's alright.
Everything's fine.
It's okay.
He's gonna slowly come over.
Alright.
He's gonna... He's gonna get closer.
He's gonna... He's gonna get closer, right?
Alright.
I can hold this for a while.
Hey!
Come on!
I'm ready!
I still have half!
Half my stamina!
Please get closer!
Yeah!
Okay.
Thank god.
I was gonna...
I thought he was just gonna stand there, messingly.
He's stuck!
He'll get there soon!
Eventually!
Oh my god.
Even you die slow.
Patient pays off.
Yay!
There's a brew there?
Oh, he's a prince?
Nice.
Now I shall be prince of the scorpions.
Okay.
Oh!
There's trees!
Alright.
What is this?
Let's see.
I was the... I was the... I was the... the...
The Newground viewers that used to watch Egoraptor.
Is that Egoraptor?
Bro, Egoraptor... Sorry.
Aaron Hansen.
He's now called Aaron Hansen.
Oh my god.
He's like 36 or something now.
And like... What's his name?
Dan... Dan Avedon is like in his 40s.
Or older.
Isn't he older than 36?
Or is he 36?
Alright.
We go... this way.
Right?
Is this the brew?
Oh, he's in his 50s now?
Holy shit.
And they're still doing Game Grumps.
I don't know.
That should be like...
Some people say I play video games just like Aaron Hansen from Game Grumps.
And I don't think they meant that as a compliment.
Guys, I... I don't think they meant that as a... as a good thing.
They do not.
Guys, I sometimes read.
Like...
Sometimes I read.
I'm already...
Look.
10% is still 10% more.
I don't even know what Game Grumps does.
Alright.
Nice.
We did it.
Yeah!
I beat video games!
Exactly!
Even if I don't...
Even if I don't read fully...
At least I still beat the game.
That's something!
Toki is glad.
How can she read?
That's true.
Oh!
Nice.
Is that it?
Oh my god.
There's so many places to go.
Have I been here?
No.
I haven't broke the jars yet.
I'm like trying to use the jars as like indicators of if I've been there or not.
No.
I have.
This is where I could...
Wait.
No.
I have.
This is...
I think I went backwards!
This is where I killed the fucking Scorpion Prince!
Okay.
Nevermind.
I just forgot to kill...
I just forgot to hit those specific jars.
Alright.
It's fine.
I didn't echolocate hard enough.
There's a spawn in the sack.
Another one.
I never complain!
There's no...
And I never lie on the internet.
Hahaha!
Alright.
Let's see what I got.
Oh!
I got the brew!
Guys.
It's not complaining.
It's called critiquing.
Hahaha!
I am just giving an honest journalistic critique.
Oh!
Another spider lady?
How many spider ladies are there?
How does it still kill my frames?
How many polygons does the spider lady have?
Hahaha!
How many polygons do you have, spider lady?
All of them.
Not enough.
Is this the story similar to the...
Steven Chao movie with the two spider ladies?
Okay.
Remove.
Haha!
The polygons.
Alright.
Nice.
Taking...
Okay.
Now that I know it doesn't fucking work.
I'm putting back my shadows to medium.
It doesn't work.
How the fuck do I fix this?
Okay.
Apply.
I guess we're just gonna look at the...
I don't...
It is a critique!
It is a...
It's not complaining.
It was...
It's my voice!
It's just my intonation!
Okay.
Where do I go?
It isn't though!
Alright.
This way.
Okay.
Let's get rid of this guy first.
Nice.
Is there special settings for just the spider lady?
Can I lower the spider lady's polygons?
That's like all I want.
Hahaha!
Whatever is up with that spider lady is killing my frames.
Alright.
Let's see.
I don't even know where to go anymore.
I feel like I'm just forever lost.
Uh...
This is such a...
Oh my god.
There's...
That's a deep hole.
I'm pretty sure I have to go there soon.
Are you serious?
There's so many like...
tunnels and directions to go.
Oh.
Get rid of the worm.
No worm for you.
Nobody loves you.
These are the worms where the boyfriends or girlfriends say, No, I do not love you.
You were a worm.
That's what they look like.
This is where they go when their significant other says no.
Alright.
Turning down reflection quality and global illumination?
Okay.
Hahaha!
The poor worms.
I'll put you out of your misery.
The unlovable worms.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Turn down reflection quality and global illumination.
I'll try that.
Uh...
I'll put that.
And then reflection.
Alright.
Let's see how shitty the game looks now.
It's not that bad.
Oh wait.
No.
This is pretty...
Hahaha!
Okay.
No.
It looks pretty good.
It's pretty ugly.
No.
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
Wait.
Hahaha!
The realization was...
I was like, okay, wait.
No.
It's actually pretty bad.
It actually is.
Oh shit.
Okay.
We got to get rid of the flies first.
It's a no-fly zone!
Remember that!
It's fine.
It's just one guy.
Get him out of here.
It's only for spotted lady!
It's fine.
Oh, brew.
Do I have another one?
What's this?
It's like say poison state to the destined one himself?
Okay.
No.
What's this?
When that critical health massively increases the recovery?
Hmm.
I don't think that's worth it.
I don't know.
I like the mana.
Actually, I should...
I don't know because it's 24%.
Yeah.
I don't think it's worth it.
The mana is definitely not worth it because I don't use mana anymore.
So I should get rid of that.
Okay.
I should use something else.
Yeah.
I'm gonna get the movement speed.
Laurel and peach pit.
I'm gonna get this cause I don't use...
Uhhhhhh...
I don't use any of these.
Peach pit...
I might as well just try this.
What does the poison state mean?
What is the...
Is it like I can get somebody to get poisoned?
Do they get poison or something?
Is that what it is?
Oh, I get- Why the fuck would I use this?
But I wanna be poisoned!
There's like nothing- There's no other positivity!
Oh, there's a weapon where I hit harder if I'm poisoned.
I was gonna say that's so fucked.
What if I just poison myself?
I wouldn't think of that first.
The risk versus- Nobody is gonna kill me, I'm just gonna poison myself.
I'll finish my own job.
You know, as a joke.
Alright, I'm pretty sure something's gonna- Oh no?
I get this for free?
Me?
I'm doing myself.
Alright, get back up though.
The fuck?
Can I get back up?
I can't get back up either?
There's no way.
No, I should be able to- Oh, it's over here.
This tiny rock.
Okay, it was this tiny rock.
Uhh...
Alright.
I guess I live here- Woah!
Oh, it's you again!
I haven't seen you in a long time!
Alright, nice.
Sometimes they have- Okay, it's like five- Oh wait, rice cocoon.
Okay.
I heard the rice cocoon is for a quest, so I might as well.
These guys are like not that scary compared to like the spiders.
The spider- The spider monsters.
The spider monsters are like a pain in the ass.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
I guess I'll go this way?
Oh, that's a- Wow.
That looks very threatening.
Guys, do you think this is dangerous?
They're not monkey skulls.
So like- All I'm saying is that they're not monkey skulls.
So like, you know, they could be like- It could be safe, you know?
If they're not monkey skulls.
Like, maybe it has a preference for humans only.
Like- Can't be that bad.
Oh, there's a cutscene.
Oh, they're- Oh!
Oh, centipig, why?
Oh, no!
Why the fuck- Okay.
This is fucked.
Cause like, he- He basically made it so I couldn't- Are you serious?
Guys- Guys, I'm gonna die so I can-
I'm gonna die on purpose, guys.
I've been first trying way too many times.
I'm gonna die for the views, guys.
Guys, I'm gonna die for the views right now.
Okay?
If I die, it's not because I'm bad.
Wait, he was rest- Wait, I could've just- Oh, my God!
Like-
Okay, nice.
Not nice.
Okay, now that I know that when he- When he does the pill for him, like- That's just nothing.
Alright, bee poisoning isn't so bad.
Like- It's just a way of life.
It's just a little bit, you know?
It's just a little joke.
Okay- Oh, that's why!
He hit his head and now he's like- I'm sad.
Like, that's understandable, you know?
That's understandable.
Anybody would be sad after.
Oh, what does that do?
What the fuck?
Oh, that's what- What the fuck?!
What the fuck?!
Oh, God.
This is not fair.
Please.
Guys, remember.
If I die- Guys, remember.
If I die, it's just- It's just- It's just for funny.
It's just for the views, guys.
Remember that.
I'm only doing it for the views.
It's not because I'm bad.
Oh, God.
Come on.
He's so low.
Please.
Yes!
I don't need the views.
I don't need- That's fucking right!
First try!
Wow!
Another one!
No views.
Jesus Christ.
Why he's so ugly?
I don't know.
Raw seeds grow in ancient silence.
Someone cast- Oh, no.
Is it like- Something is super- Like, important?
I'm sorry for calling you ugly.
The content dogi!
The content- All right.
Nice.
I just want to look at what I missed.
Novel in Captain- Oh.
Oh, I killed all of these guys.
The wolf archer.
What about the bugs?
Oh, there they are.
The puppet spider.
The grasshopper.
The wasp.
The stone spider.
The worm.
The claw.
Oh, the claw cocoon.
And the scorpion prince.
Just follow the script, please!
Toki!
You're supposed to lose!
Stop killing all of them!
I missed two monk boss?
I could go back.
Instant transmission.
Wait, where do I go?
Stop deeming!
Guys, you have to be specific on where to go.
Because, like, we have a problem.
Hahaha!
Over there.
Guys, so where do I go?
Oh, chapter three?
Okay.
Chapter three?
I have to go all the way back?
How do I get there?
Chapter three?
Wait, when did I kill another monk?
I killed so many things, like, I can't tell anymore.
Chapter three?
Okay.
Alright, where else?
Where do I have to go?
Guys, you have to be very specific as to what the monk is.
Like, I've killed so many things.
Thunderclap.
What is the thunderclap thing?
Is this chapter three?
There's no thunderclap here.
The first?
Oh, the old dude!
Oh!
That guy!
The new thunderclap temple.
Oh, there it is!
Oh, there's just the beginning?
Is it, uh, a temple entrance?
That guy!
The guy that killed his fox wife!
Alright.
Wait, how did they appear?
Why did they appear again?
Didn't I kill the monks already?
Or did I not?
Did I, like, miss the... did I miss the optional...
optional bosses from them?
When I did chapter three?
Did I miss it?
Or, like, did they only appear after I finished chapter three?
Alright.
Did they, like, appear after I finished chapter three or did I just miss it?
I can't tell, guys.
Oh, I just missed it then.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
When did you get so strong?
What the fuck?
When did these guys get so strong?
They're just mobs!
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Okay, this is it.
Alright.
I don't know...
I don't understand.
I used to be so strong.
What happened?
How did he get so strong?
How did you get just a mob?
Oh my god.
You were just...
Oh, I was at the wrong area.
Okay.
I wasn't even supposed to be here.
Like, like...
Dude, they only give me, like, 393.
It's not even that much.
Alright.
So, it's the...
Alright, so it has to be at the end of it then.
Uh...
Oh, wait.
I need to rest anyway.
Uh...
Web parlor...
Wait, no, not web parlor.
Uh...
The hall.
It's him, the god of war.
It's him.
Okay, to the left.
To the left, to the left.
Alright, are they still guarding?
Why are you still guarding?
They're dead.
Alright, how much HP am I gonna lose?
Guys.
I'm gonna do a flip.
Guys, I'm gonna do a flip.
Guys, I'm going to do a flip.
Guys, I'll do it.
Guys, you think I won't?
Haha!
There, see?
I did...
Did you see the flip?
It was so fast.
The human eye could not comprehend it.
Wait, let me get the camera.
Haha!
No!
Okay, nice.
Is this the left side?
Wait, I went right.
I'm gonna grab some water.
I went right.
Okay.
It was very obvious where it was.
Instructions unclear.
I lost the 50-50.
Guys, I don't know how.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
I'm gonna do a flip again!
I'm gonna flip again.
Flip again!
Okay, let's see.
Oh wait, I don't have to do a flip.
Oh no, I do.
It's an invisible wall.
Oh, JK, I lose 0 HP.
Let's fucking go.
Guys, I lost the 50-50.
Alright.
Here I come.
But your god's dead.
Non-pure?
Wait, you're not pure?
Wait, why do you have a...
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Okay.
What if I just meditate in front of you?
Wouldn't that be funny?
Unless...
Okay, let's get...
Oh shit!
Let's just have full HP just in case.
Like, I don't wanna risk it.
I don't wanna risk it.
In general.
Wait, is he block...
I can't tell if he's blocking me or not.
Alright.
Cause he's holding his hand out as if he's blocking me.
But like, he's... Oh shit!
Alright, that's fine.
Boom!
Wow!
Haha, you missed, bitch.
I did not mean that.
I'm so sorry.
Let me charge it up.
I imagine missing.
Oh shit, I'm so sorry.
I don't mean that.
I don't mean that!
No!
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
Nice.
Okay, so low.
He's so low.
Come on!
Yes!
Easy.
So fucking easy.
Absorb.
Sorry, I forgot to use my echolocation there.
I keep forgetting to echolocate.
Oh, I get to meditate.
Nice.
No longer shall I pretend I'm bad at this game.
Hahaha.
I will no longer pretend I'm bad at this game for views.
I will prove them all wrong.
Hahaha.
It is no longer for content anymore.
She's changed.
She got one guy so hard.
Hahaha.
She got one guy so hard that she's actually locked in.
Alright.
Where do we go next?
Wait, where's the other monk?
No key.
This is not part.
He lives rent free in my head.
Hahaha.
I'll go down the stairs.
Okay.
This spider's too powerful.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Wait, how did he see me?
I'm just walking down the stairs.
Okay, where do I go from here?
Book of bliss?
Okay.
Instant transmission.
Pagoda realm.
Alright.
Just a little guy.
Travel in the west.
Where do we go?
In pagoda realm?
Uhhhhh.
I already did the fox quest so we're missing a monk.
I'm just a little guy.
Valley of ecstasy.
It's not in pagoda realm.
What the fuck?
Guys, you're giving me different locations.
Which one is it?
Is it valley or is it pagoda realm?
Book of bliss?
Book of bliss.
Okay, here.
Okay.
We're at the book of bliss.
Alright, here we are.
Now where do we go?
I don't even remember this location.
Like, when did I get here?
Up the stairs?
Okay.
When was I ever here?
Oh hey, there's two wills here.
Is this left?
No, this was right.
Where?
This way, right?
Is that left?
Yeah, but I saw like...
Guys, I couldn't help it.
I saw will.
I needed xp.
Guys, xp important.
Can we go up?
Oh, is it that tower over there?
Okay, no, it's not.
Oh, is it him?
Is it this guy?
The non-A-bun?
What you gonna do?
You don't have arms?
Oh shit!
What are you doing?
You're fucking dancing!
Bro, this guy should be brick dancing!
Like...
Bro, this guy should represent Australia brick dancing!
Holy shit, look at him!
Go!
Guys, I think he might have two phases.
Because he's gonna be able to...
Guys, there's no way.
There's no way.
No, he no.
Ray gun.
Oh my god, look at him!
He just did the move!
That's better than the kill!
He literally...
He literally fucking... look at him go!
He spun on his head.
He's got the moves!
Alright, nice.
Oh, that is definitely it.
Alright.
Kill without...
Is he still non-A-bun?
Guys, I don't...
God, you have your arms now!
You gotta change your name!
Holy fuck!
Oh, okay.
Don't let that happen to you.
I know that now.
He's able now!
There's no way!
You're still a non-A-bun!
You untied your arms!
Your name doesn't work anymore!
Okay.
It's fine.
Alright, it's fine.
Oh, shit!
Guys.
Guys, I'm desperate.
No!
No, stop!
Guys, just remember.
If I lose, you know why.
Guys, I gotta follow the script, guys!
I'm just following the script, guys!
I'm just following the script!
Oh,
she's finally doing it.
She's finally doing it!
It's all part of the plan.
For the viewers!
Oh, my God.
Welcome, new viewers!
For the content.
She's engagement farming.
She's finally done it!
She's finally engagement farming!
Now she's relatable!
I also lost to that boss!
And she lost to that boss, too!
Oh, my God!
She's relatable now!
She's...
I can finally relate to her!
Knowing that, like, we both lost to the same boss!
She's just like me!
Jesus Christ!
Can you figure out how his fucking movement...
I'm not thinking right now.
To be fair, I never think.
Okay.
What?!
You just stepped!
Like...
She's a real...
Okay, I'm gonna...
Hydrate real fast.
Oh, how does your defense go up when your arms are untied?
It doesn't make sense!
Like, it's still the same body!
Like...
How do you have more defense?
Literally the same body!
Okay.
Come on.
Get closer.
The fuse actually went up!
Wait, did it really?
Oh, my God!
I can finally relate to the streamer now!
Let me watch here.
He got more angry, so he doesn't feel pain.
Oh, shit!
Oh, God.
Holy shi- Why is he so much harder than, like, the other non-ape nine months?
Doesn't make fucking sense!
You're from the same place!
Okay.
Oh.
All right.
Fuck me out, I guess.
Get closer.
But not too close.
Oh, God.
Thank God.
Okay.
Two tries.
I can feel the veer count go up.
Thank you for the super chat, Mike.
Thank you.
Nice.
I did it.
I believed enough.
Now you're not relatable anymore.
Unsubscribe.
Close tab.
Nice.
Instant transmission.
You did it!
And for that reason, I shall now close the tab.
Wait, do I have to go to the Great Pagoda now?
Chat?
Will you find the fat mob?
Like, longevity.
Uh...
Longevity.
Where the fuck?
This one?
Back to being lost.
Here?
What mob?
S1, thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you.
There's apparently a big mob for armor?
We are not the same.
I'm leaving.
Can you not unlock it?
Outside of new game plot?
I thought you could unlock it before.
I know about the secret ending.
Or like the second ending.
I'm not gonna pretend.
I know about the that there is a second ending.
But like, uh...
I thought you could unlock it before.
I need to beat the chapter 6 final boss.
Now I don't know much about the second ending, but I know that you can unlock the second ending.
By doing stuff.
Yeah, I thought you could do the second ending before the final boss.
Oh, shit.
Alright, get this out of here.
Straight up?
Just up?
Okay.
Up.
I think this is up.
What the fuck?
Okay.
We already killed this guy before.
Wait, do we have to kill him?
Oh, what the fuck?
There's a crow too?
Oh!
We don't have to kill him.
Oh, him?
Oh, I thought you meant...
I thought you meant, like, giant mob.
I thought you meant, like, a lot of people.
Not an actual giant.
Like...
I was like, where's the giant mob?
It can't be that big thing up there.
Like, it can't be him.
Like...
It's just one guy.
I was gonna be like, that's just one guy and it can't be him.
I didn't...
I didn't realize you mean, like, actual giant mob.
I thought I killed one of these before.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure you can unlock this secret boss before you do, uh...
Unless I'm wrong.
I could be wrong.
I'm wrong about a lot of stuff.
Goodbye feet!
Oh, nice!
Keep hitting your feet.
I know I could hit your head, but fuck your feet.
But, like, not fuck your feet, but fuck your feet.
Oh, nice!
I got it!
Boop!
Yeah, you have to do the secret boss before the final boss to unlock it.
I heard about that.
Burrito, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright.
Alright, where do we go?
Where do we go now?
Can we continue the web hollow?
I guess I'm at the middle hollow, right?
Cosmic, thank you for the super chat!
Oh, I forgot the chest!
Oh my god, you're right.
I forgot, but this can't be that important.
Guys, there's no way!
There's no...
I'm pretty sure it's not that important.
How important could it be?
How important was that chest anyway?
Like, it can't be that important!
Hahaha!
There's no way!
There's no way it was that important, guys.
Hahaha!
The iron leaf, Toki!
Think about the iron!
Bro, I have 40 iron leaves!
I don't need more!
It's game changing.
Hahaha!
Toki!
Toki, it could be 41!
It could be 41 iron leaves!
Toki, you need the chest for the secret ending!
Toki!
But what if you need 41 iron leaves?
41!
Hahaha!
It could be 42!
You're lucky!
Alright, where do I go?
Oh, it's 42.
It's 42!
Thank you!
Ba dum ba dum!
Alright, nice.
Is this way?
Oh my god, it's actually 42.5?
This is one of my favorite movies.
I wonder what happened to Martin Freeman.
I swear.
Oh yeah!
Marvel happened.
So now he's not in any other good movies anymore.
Hahaha!
He was in Marvel...
Marvel is where actors go to retire.
Hahaha!
True!
I don't know.
I feel like when you start getting Marvel parts, like, you just don't do anything else after that.
It's just, you're just a Marvel character now.
Alright.
Whoa!
That's a big ass egg!
Is this gonna be a worm?
Wait, it's breathing.
Why is it breathing?
What the fuck?
How did you get here?
Oh, are they consuming it?
Do they also get stronger?
This is the weird thing about The way that they come out with the fire thing.
The way that they come out with fire.
Are they using the fire thing?
Do they use fire?
Oh, I mean, Wait, I thought I was the only destined one.
He got corrupted.
Wait, isn't it me?
Wait, you were looking for me all along?
You could have helped me in Chapter 1!
Why does this big, beefy man get captured all the time?
Why can't I talk?
Why can't I just write...
Okay, if I can't talk, why can't I just write on the sand and be like, I'm the destined one.
Can he not read?
Is he stupid?
Can I not write?
Am I stupid?
He's a hater.
And Vogue grows all muscle and no brain.
He's a monkey.
Of course he can't read.
Am I illiterate?
Like, I know I am in real life, but like...
I thought in game I could be anybody I wanna be, and I wanna be a monkey that can read.
All I ever need!
How do I not know I'm the destined one?
Everybody says I'm...
Literally, the first monkeys told me I'm the destined one!
How do I just somehow forgot I'm the destined one?
Literally, that's literally what everybody keeps telling me.
They're like, you're the destined one.
Save Xun Hong...
You have to grab the fucking artifacts!
Yeah, but I could just write, I could just write in the fucking sand, in the grass and be like, I'll just, I could use my fingers, whenever he says Zest in one, I point at myself, like, me?
You know, like, man pointing at yourself emoji, like, I literally could just point at myself.
Okay, literally, this is what I could do.
Wait, is he dead?
I want, okay, he's dead for real.
I was gonna tab out and he would be, like, still alive, like, man pointing at himself emoji.
Wait, where is it?
I could just, okay, this is what I could do, guys.
Every time...
Every time horseman...
Is like...
Okay, let me make sure I draw correctly too.
Okay, the red strands are his hair, by the way, guys, if you guys need to know.
And then...
Okay, and then...
Uh...
Here we go.
Guys, the red strands... Okay, let me make sure, I'm gonna erase the red strands and use black, because that would make more sense.
Guys, the joke page is...
The payoff is worth it, guys.
Guys, the payoff for this joke is so worth it.
Okay?
It's up to my father to illustrate this.
It'll be so worth it, I swear to God.
I swear to God.
The joke would be so worth it.
Okay, there you go.
So, every time...
Every time...
Every time the horseman is like...
Oh my God, I'm here to find the destined one.
I could literally just be like...
Me?
Like...
That's all I have to do!
They don't know!
There it is!
I could just be like...
Me?
I told...
That's his tail!
I just forgot to draw it in red.
I just forgot to draw this in red.
Um...
DY, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello from Rin.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just...
Guys...
I didn't have a lot of time to do this artwork.
Like, you understand the joke?
Okay!
As long as you understand the joke.
Nice and intelligent.
Keep it.
That's fucked.
Alright.
Nice.
Got another...
Another worm.
Wait, is there something here?
Oh, it's just...
Gatter.
Oh, it's just Jade Lotus.
Okay.
Look, I needed the visuals to explain my joke better.
So that you guys will think I'm funny.
Bye bye, worm.
Bye bye.
So many fucking worms.
At least they're like super...
They're just super tanky.
But they're so annoying to fight.
Because they're so tanky.
Like...
Oh, no!
I'm sorry for calling you easy.
You're the only exception, baby girl.
Baby worm.
I didn't mean that, baby worm.
You're not easy.
The karma.
Don't worry.
I got him.
Alright.
I told you.
So fucking easy.
I don't like the little...
Nubby face.
It's a fucking worm!
What do you even want?
You want...
Okay, if...
Okay, more...
It's more like a caterpillar.
If you want a caterpillar to have long ass legs, that's even more freaky.
Like, I don't think you'd like a caterpillar with long ass fucking legs.
That shit is freaky.
Oh, hey.
That's another shrine.
Oh, shit.
Oh, dear.
No flat zone!
What did I tell you?
Got to teach you that lesson again, old man.
Oh, shit.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I can't be relatable.
I can't die to the mobs.
Alright.
I'll just grab this chest.
What did I get?
Okay, refined iron sand.
Alright, I can just literally ignore them.
Alright.
And thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Tell everyone I love them.
I hope you're all having fun, especially those drinking a Baja Blast with cheese.
Is this like an advertisement from Burger King?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You guys know Burger King used to do...
Like, not Burger King.
I don't remember.
Corporations on Twitch.
So, like...
Okay, so I don't know if corporations still do this.
But, like...
Um...
Back...
I don't...
Back then, like...
Uh...
Like, I think for, like, two or three years ago.
Or maybe, like, even, like...
Still today.
When you see corporations...
Uh...
Corporations...
Oh, sorry.
Taco Bell.
I've never had a Baja Blast, guys.
I've never...
Guys, I've never had a Baja Blast.
I...
I just assumed it was from Burger King.
Anyway.
So, like, when corporations...
Um...
On Twitch, GIF, like...
Sub...
Sorry.
I keep forgetting that on Twitch it's subscribers.
So, like, for those who don't know, on Twitch, memberships on YouTube is, like, subscribers on Twitch.
Um...
And when corporations, uh, gift, like, subscriptions on Twitch, it's an...
It's easier advertisement versus, like, sponsoring a streamer.
Because when you used to gift subscription, it, like, shows up that you, like, gifted a lot.
Like, you show up on the very top being, like, most gifted.
So then you show up on, like, big channels and, uh, you show up on big channels, um, with your, like, name of your corporation and stuff.
So that's why you would see, like, big companies, like, gift big streamers lots and lots of subscription.
Because it's, like, a billboard ad and it's a lot cheaper, um...
It's a lot cheaper than, uh, uh, than paying the streamer.
Uh...
I don't know if they still do.
I don't know if they still do that.
Like...
That's sneaky.
It is.
It's very sneaky.
I don't know if I'm supposed to go down here.
I don't think I was supposed to go down...
There's so much HP!
Like, what the fuck?
Oh, wait, no.
This was, like, the beginning.
The army used to run Twitch ads.
Not in America, so, like, it's not targ...
I don't get the targeted ads.
No, because you show...
Because on Twitch, it's...
You show up on...
Um...
You show up at the...
Why did it...
Oh, this left!
Wait, there's nothing here.
What?
Why did...
Who told me to go left?!
Did you tell me to go left because you wanted me to fall?!
That's fucked.
That's so fucked.
Like, where...
What is that?
There's nothing there!
This is the beginning!
I don't know.
Yes.
That's so fucked.
Wait.
What's that hand holding?
Oh.
I don't know.
This is, like, Stranger Danger right there.
It's like, hey.
Hey, little monkey.
You want some candy?
Guys, do I take the candy?
Like...
There's surely nothing back there.
That will happen if I take the mysterious...
Oh!
It's the mirror!
Wow.
I can't believe it.
Something bad happened.
Oh, shit!
Who would've thought?
That hand is actually bad hand.
Damn.
Biggest plot twist of my life.
Oh, shit!
As if things would actually be this easy.
How is that the Buddha's right hand?
What the fuck?
You're...
Okay.
Bro.
How is this hand so hard to kill?
Okay.
This hand is pissing me off.
Am I gonna be able to use the combo at all?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Thank God.
Jesus Christ!
Fucking stupid hand!
Bro!
He's fucking...
I'm going back up before I can do a combo!
This is bullshit!
No!
Oh!
I can't figure out this combo!
He's just moving like a hand!
Wait.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is that?
What's going on?
Wait.
What?
I am so...
I am so confused.
Like...
That is not a hand.
That was not a hand.
It was just bait.
Imagine losing...
Losing to a hand.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, that guy confused the shit out of me.
First try!
Wait.
Did I die?
What was that?
I'm gonna die.
I'm alive.
Okay.
It was his tail?
Oh, my God.
It was.
It's not even a hand.
Hot goth lady.
Hot goth spider lady.
Wait.
Are you serious?
Wait, I didn't even ask for your help.
He's like, I will no longer help you now.
It's like, well, I never asked for it.
Like, you just showed up.
Oh no, go outside.
What's stopping you?
Literally nothing's stopping you from going outside.
Greg, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Need a hand with that?
Alright, nice.
Her mom.
Bro, what the fuck is her mom gonna do?
Like, kill her?
Bro, she has so many kids.
You're literally not the only hot spider lady.
She has so many children.
She's not gonna notice.
Just leave.
Alright, nice.
Maximum mana.
We need that.
Now you go.
Okay, I went left, guys.
Now you go left, Doki.
Is he actually the Buddha's hand?
Or is that bait?
There's no way.
Let's just double check.
Oh, do I have a new relic?
Whoa!
Okay, that's a lot of new relics.
Increases poison resistance.
Moderately increases poison damage.
Considerably increases defense.
Deals damage to surrounding enemies upon taking a hit.
Oh, wait.
What do I have?
Okay, critical hit.
Linus.
Okay.
What's this?
Slightly...
Oh, okay.
I don't need this then.
Um...
I guess I'll get this, the defense.
I wanna see...
What?
Wait.
Equipment.
Do I have another gourd?
Amount of burn resistance and immunity from lava-covered terrain.
Each sip contains 36% of maximum health.
Oh, wait.
This is eight.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why do I even read that?
Why do I even need to read that?
That's eight.
Eight is more than...
Eight is more than seven.
Okay, I wanna see what the Buddha right hand looks like.
Alright.
The hand that plucked the lotus of the saint, yet not from the same egg.
Who in the olden days... Is he actually the Buddha's right hand?
Wait, he's left-handed?
Oh, no!
He has a brother!
I was gonna be like, wait, he's left-handed?
Then this is bait!
This is...
I was like, wait, there's no way...
Sorry, I was speed reading.
Oh, okay.
Oh, so he has a twin!
He has a twin!
I was gonna be like, what the fuck?
You're actually...
You're left-handed, but they call you right-hand Bill.
Alright, let's see.
I guess we go this way.
Oh, there's two ways.
Which way do we go?
Do we go left or right, chat?
Left side?
Okay.
I'll go left.
There's a mysterious bridge.
Hey, that's nice!
The spiders know how to build bridges!
Where's the Buddha?
Of course.
Oh.
That's nice of them, being able to build bridges.
These guys are so easy to kill.
They're like babies.
But they give me 105, which is nice.
I like it when babies give 105.
Get your head over here.
And they don't fight back, too.
Like actual babies.
Alright, nice.
Chest time.
Yay!
Guys!
Guys, I finally have more iron leaves!
It's your favorite!
Wait, that's a lot.
Oh, no.
Wait a minute.
Can they whack me?
Wait a...
Guys.
I have a feeling they're about to whack me.
It's fine.
If I whack them first, they can't whack me.
Let's get rid of all of them here.
No!
I wanna whack!
You can't tell me what to do!
Whack!
I shall whack them all!
What are they gonna do, kill me?
I can't even...
Still alive.
This is so...
I'm just going to fall off...
As I was sitting...
No!
Let me back up!
No, I got a bug!
There's an invisible, there's an actual.
There's an- There's,
there's an...
But there's an actual...
Actual invisible wall!
There I go!
Okay, guys.
I found...
Guys, I found out that...
Guys, I don't know if you know this.
But...
But you can actually fall.
You can actually fall there.
That's...
That's good to know.
Okay.
But the prison level taught me that I couldn't fall!
Why can't I fall now?
It doesn't make any sense.
In the prison level, I could just walk wherever I wanted.
So relatable.
Okay.
Alright, now I know.
Okay, I'll use cloud step now.
I'll use cloud step.
Alright.
Alright, now I know why everyone kept telling me to use cloud step.
Now I know.
Alright.
This time it'll be different.
Alright, get rid of these guys first.
Get rid of the babies.
Get out of here, babies!
You don't deserve to be here.
Be gone, babies!
Be gone!
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Okay, now that I know that I can just walk through here as a little cloud.
Oh, absorb!
Oh hey, that was easy.
Hey, that was easy.
Wow, that was so easy.
Alright, nice.
Let's go this way.
Oh, it's the moth guy!
Wait, this is bad.
I can't afford the...
I don't have the...
Wait, I could swap wards to recover my mana, actually.
I was gonna say, this is bad because I have no magic technically.
Or my magic is super fucking weak.
Oh, unlucky.
It's fine.
Whoa!
That's fine.
Nice.
What if the sack have iron leaves, Doki?
Think about the iron leaves!
You could have 45 iron leaves, Doki!
Think about it!
Oh yeah, I didn't see this guy.
Okay, what if like... I'm gonna...
Where's that thing that increases mana?
Uh, increases speed...
Oh, I have... God, I have to do it at the incense.
I forgot.
It's at the incense area.
Yeah.
I have to do it at the incense.
I forgot.
That's the only way to change these thingies.
Oh, thank god he hit the tree.
He missed.
Don't worry, echolocation!
Echolocated!
It's that easy.
Poke!
Where is it?
There he is!
Echolocation!
Now, like, when people ask you, why does she laugh so much?
It's her form of...
It's her form of direction.
Of a compass.
Alright, nice.
Alright, leaves.
Oh!
Nice.
We need that.
That's the material.
Uh...
Which way?
This way.
Hey, there's Mountain.
He's here.
Why would that hot spider lady...
Oh my god.
God damn it.
Oh.
I was gonna say I faced the wrong way.
Holy shit!
What a propeller!
Okay.
Guess we go this way.
Oh, I should've not wasted my power up there.
The heavy attack there.
Cause I could've used it on this guy.
This guy is a bigger threat!
Jesus!
Fuck!
God damn it.
Alright.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
I'm not okay.
JK!
It's alright.
It's okay.
I don't wanna be relatable.
If I don't die to a normal mob, I'll never be relatable.
Cause I'm Virtua.
Where the fuck is it?
Wait.
Where's the incense?
Oh, it's this way.
What?
No, it's not.
Oh, it's over here.
The thing that's covered in all the smoke.
There it is.
She's too quick at this.
Alright, rest.
Okay, that's good.
I don't have to change the silks then.
There's a new one?
Increases maximum... Oh!
Wait, that's good.
Who needs poison?
Yeah, that's good.
Like, I know this entire world is based off of poison.
But like, who needs...
I just think like we don't...
I'll get better.
I'll just recover.
It's okay.
Guys, I can just...
I can fix myself.
Alright, nice.
Poke!
Jesus.
That's so much damage.
God damn it!
Okay.
These beetles are so annoying!
For a regular mob!
Alright.
Oh my god.
They give me like $600?
Okay, yeah.
No wonder.
These guys are so fucking...
Wait, wrong way?
Which way do I go?
This way?
Go back to the shrine?
Is this an optional boss over there?
Okay, I'm gonna rest up then.
I was like, is this an optional boss?
And someone's like, yeah.
And the other person's like, no.
Oh, cutscene?
Who's he?
Guys, I'm not lagging.
It's the hot goth lady.
Spider lady.
The hot spider goth lady has too many polygons.
Oh no.
I didn't kill anybody!
Oh!
Wait, you're a...
Okay, I killed all your brothers and sisters.
Never mind.
I fucked up!
Okay, I already fucked...
It's okay, I want it to be relatable.
That's why.
I wanted...
I fucked up.
He interrupted me.
It's okay.
Wait, does this use magic?
It doesn't, right?
Okay.
Come on, please!
Let me use one move!
Oh my god, I haven't used this in so long.
Okay, nice.
Okay, it does it.
So I'm fine.
Oh no.
Oh no, I think this is over.
I'm not gonna be relatable.
No, I have to be relatable!
The moment he interrupted the first attack.
Oh god.
Wait, what is he doing?
What is he doing?
I don't know what that move is!
No!
He's in the air!
How do I hit things in the air?
Oh god.
Monkey's scared!
Monkey's so scared!
Poke!
Guys, I only did like one...
Not even one third!
Like one sixth damage!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
He's so cool.
Holy shit!
This guy is so difficult!
Okay, it didn't help that...
It definitely...
Um...
It definitely did not help that, you know...
I messed up...
I messed up my spellbinder.
I messed it up.
Okay.
Alright.
God fucking...
Okay, fine.
Okay, that is not a lot of damage.
Wait a minute!
That...
That is not a lot of damage!
Even with...
Even with the spellbinder!
It did so little!
Wait, he's the first one.
I did kill all his little brothers and sisters.
Oh my god.
Guys, yeah, you think I did more than the last...
Yeah, no shit.
No shit.
Okay.
Can I craft new stuff?
Do I have...
Do I have stronger...
No, I do not.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's a-okay.
That's totally fine.
That's...
That's fine.
It's...
It's okay.
I have an idea.
That's not the idea.
That...
By the way, guys.
I don't know if you know this, but that was not the idea I was thinking of.
That wasn't it.
Like...
Now...
This is it.
What do you mean you cheese it with heavy...
Like that?
Jesus Christ.
Maybe if I...
Maybe if I cheese it too.
Like that?
Guys.
Okay.
Okay, we just gotta regen.
Okay, we can do this.
Okay, wait.
I have an idea.
That's not the idea.
Please.
Okay.
Okay, I have...
Guys, I think it's working.
Okay.
Guys, I...
Guys.
I don't think it's working.
I can't...
I didn't think...
Guys, I don't think it's working.
Guys.
It needs to be...
Oh my god.
No.
I figured it out.
Somebody says use this.
I figured it out, guys.
This is it.
It's wolf hours.
Wolf...
Big baby!
Okay.
Fine.
I
told you!
I told you!
The moment I dodged this!
What?!
Okay, but like...
Oh, it works!
Fuck!
Okay.
Oh, shit!
I didn't even realize this human was still there.
I was too busy.
Okay.
Let's level this up.
Alright.
What makes it so that no longer falls?
Okay, we need that.
No longer falls.
Alright, guys.
Guys.
Guys, we're gonna be okay.
We no longer fall.
Guys, we no longer fall now.
Guys.
Guys, we're no longer gonna fall anymore.
Guys, we fixed the problem.
We...
We fixed the issue.
We fixed it.
Oh my god.
We fixed the problem.
No!
Okay.
Okay, I thought I fucked up.
I always think I fucked up.
That's fine.
We fixed the issue.
What you gonna do now?
That's fucking right.
I figure out the cheese.
That's right!
You can't do anything!
Oh
my god!
Okay, I can keep doing this.
Boom!
Ow.
It's fine.
I figured it out.
Okay.
This is fine.
Can't do anything now!
Okay.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, I'm sorry!
No!
I'm so sorry!
Okay,
I'm learning his combos.
Pride comes before the fall.
It's okay.
Evil Shock, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, okay, but like...
I figured it out.
I know what to do now.
There's no way.
I know what to do.
It's so over for him.
It's so over.
There's nothing else he can do now.
Now that I shall master...
Hey, baby.
I have mastered...
I have mastered the pillar.
That's fucking right.
What you gonna do?
Nothing!
That's fucking right.
I am taking damage.
Okay.
All right.
Now that I know he can still do something when I'm up there, that's okay.
But what you gonna do now?
Nothing!
Okay.
Still something.
No, I should...
Oh!
Okay.
We can do this.
I'm gonna lock in.
I'm gonna lock it in.
This is fine.
Okay.
It's okay.
We figured it out, though.
Like, we're so locked in now.
We're so locked in.
Boom!
Okay.
All right.
He doesn't attack until he's closer.
That's good to know.
Guys.
He started to attack.
He started.
Because I thought you said he doesn't attack until he starts getting closer.
Why was he so far away when he attacked?
Guys!
You guys lied!
Spreading misinformation on the internet!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
It's so okay.
Let's see.
Gotta do a slam.
Oh, god.
Okay.
That was a waste.
Oh, no.
He's doing a thing.
No!
Fuck!
Okay.
When he pulls it...
I'm dying!
Oh, my god.
The timing!
This is so difficult!
It's so difficult!
Oh, my god.
Why is the timing so hard?
The cheese isn't working, guys!
Okay.
All right.
Pull focus.
Guys.
Full focus.
Okay.
All right.
Full focus.
Oh!
Full focus, Toki.
Full focus!
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Damn!
All right.
Full focus.
You got this!
What the fuck was that?
I never saw that move before!
There's more moves?
How many moves do you need?
Like...
How do you have more?
Oh, my god.
Okay.
I hate that move so much!
I can't use immobilize!
I have spellbinding!
Is spellbinding bad against him?
Do I use my other magic?
Which is better?
Spellbinding or my other magic?
Because if I use...
It's bad?
Okay.
It's time to reset.
It's time.
Okay.
All right.
Where is it?
Transformation.
Strength.
All right.
Goodbye, everything.
Goodbye.
And then Cloud Step.
Okay, I have two left.
I'll put everything else in Cloud Step now.
It increases the... alright.
Alright, there we go.
And then we'll get the Gourd.
Where's my Brew?
Okay, I need the...
It increases... it increases...
Health Recovery... I'm gonna use the Cloud Step Gourd.
Alright.
Okay, yeah.
Wait, actually...
I should grab this one then.
Because it increases my mana.
And then... it also increases how I'm using...
Cloud Step.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, but like, what if like I send in...
a bunch of my monkeys?
There we go.
It's over for you.
I figured it out.
I shall use my other moves.
There we go!
He didn't... I forgot to swap.
I still have Spellbind.
I...
I stopped...
Oh, my God!
Okay.
I...
I did not have a Plat.
Okay, let me...
Set spells...
Okay.
Now...
Now everything is where it should be.
We have so many transformations, holy shit.
I feel like wolf is the best though.
Wolf is the best, right?
The transformation.
Out of all of them, you stone?
This one?
Acer dust?
The rock why?
Or tiger?
Tiger?
Okay.
Toward a light attack.
Jesus Christ!
Okay, let me read this.
Heavy attack.
To deflect assault.
Okay.
I have a spell.
Upon full focus, convert all focus into swiftness.
With swiftness, dodging transforms, allowing you...
Alright.
Upon entering... Okay, we gotta do this.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
How do I block?
Okay, V.
Okay.
It's time.
That's fucking right.
That's... That's not right.
That's... No!
That is not right!
Can I hold it?
What you gonna do?
Nothing.
That's right!
Nothing!
I'm doing barely any damage.
I'm not gonna lie.
The damage is not that much.
Oh, do it after you transform.
Okay, that makes a lot more sense actually.
Like...
That actually makes a lot more sense.
Cause I'm just like...
Guys, I don't think I'm doing a lot of damage.
Oh, shit.
Okay, recovery.
Okay.
Oh, no!
Dodge!
I remember that moveset!
Okay.
Oh, here he goes.
Ha!
What is he gonna do?
He's gonna do that.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Ah!
Okay, I got it!
Oh, I got it!
I got it!
Oh, my God!
That move is so fucking scary!
Okay.
Oh!
Final slam!
Ah!
No!
Oh, my God!
I did so well!
It's the fi- Ah!
He does so much!
He does so much damage!
It literally one-shot me!
Oh, my God!
Bro, this is not fair!
Okay.
Alright, I feel like I have to do this then.
Like, for the big baby.
Okay.
Nice.
Did you guys set to do full focus?
Wait, I don't have full focus, though!
Guys, I don't have full focus!
Does it still work?
I don't- Oh.
Oh, God.
I don't have full focus.
I just noticed.
I- I have been upgraded to Tiger!
Okay.
Am I doing any damage?
I'm not.
Okay.
Boom.
I did it!
I didn't unlock full focus yet, guys!
I'm trapped!
I'm trapped in the grass!
I can't- I actually can't move at all!
I'm stuck!
I'm actually stuck!
Even he's like, are you okay there?
I'm not there.
I'm not.
I'm stuck in the grass.
Let me out of the grass.
Holy fuck.
I didn't even notice that.
That's so unfortunate for me.
Of course I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Leave Doki.
It's a fucking fire move.
There's no point in...
Guys, I think the wolf is better.
Because I don't have four focus.
There's like no point.
There's no point in being a tiger if I don't have four focus.
I feel like I should just stick with the wolf.
Alright, I'm gonna set spells.
If I upgrade the tiger, it still doesn't matter.
I don't have four focus though.
Do I?
Can I upgrade to four focus?
Okay.
I don't have... wait.
Do I have enough?
I don't have enough to upgrade though.
I'm pretty sure.
Do I?
Where is it?
How do I upgrade to four?
Word.
How do I upgrade it?
It's in staff stance?
Okay.
I'll take something out.
I guess I'll take...
Where is it?
I need one more.
Spend more sparks.
I need one.
I'm missing one point.
Oh my god, it's time to farm.
It's time to fucking farm.
This is what they were for.
This is why they're here.
Give me.
I need.
Please.
I need more.
Oh, this is gonna take...
Guys, this is gonna take so long.
I realize this is gonna take so long.
Maria, thank you for the magenta soup.
But it takes too long.
I'm gonna...
Wait.
What if I don't wanna take it from another tree?
But I don't wanna.
Okay.
Why not?
What?
I don't know what to...
I don't know what to take away.
I guess...
Maybe...
One of this?
Okay.
Uh...
Here we go.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
Wait.
Do I not have four?
That's not four.
That's still three.
Wait.
What the fuck?
Why does it say three?
That's not four?
Okay.
Wait.
What?
Oh!
The four...
How do I get down here?
How do I get back?
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
All right.
This is fine.
Okay.
I need a rest.
It's not fine, guys.
You know what?
No.
This is...
I need a rest.
I need the baby.
I just realized I don't...
I don't know.
I have to reset it because, like, I need the big baby.
Guys, no more.
I...
No!
I had to!
I had to, guys!
Did I hit him?
I did.
Okay.
Nice.
Thank God.
All right.
Full focus.
Full focus, guys.
No!
Why did you do that?
Full focus starting now.
It was an accident.
Okay.
All right, now we full focus.
Are you serious?
That hit...
Okay.
Full focus starting now.
Starting now.
Okay, here we go.
It starts now.
She just killed me.
Okay, here we go.
It hit all the other times!
I didn't stop hitting now!
All the other times it hit!
Oh no, how did I miss?
Okay, focus.
You got this.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, are you serious?
No!
Oh, this is the worst I've ever done!
Come on!
I'm freaking...
God, how did...
How did you miss?
Oh!
Some people said the cloud strike is better.
I think it just depends on playstyle.
I'm more used to fire...
The cloud than the fire because I like the cloud more.
It really depends on the playstyle.
I saw some people were like...
Oh, I used the cloud for him.
God.
Oh, come on!
I just need to dodge!
Oh, sorry.
I'm at the freeze.
The immobilise.
I didn't mean...
I didn't mean the cloud.
I got confused.
But, yeah, I saw people said they used immobilise for him.
Okay, nice.
All right.
Come on.
Okay.
All right, immobilise!
Wait, what?
Wait, that's it?
What the f... Okay, I did not realize what he does.
Okay, now that I know what one does.
All right.
Now I know what it does guys.
Oh god.
Oh!
He's so strong!
THRUST WAS THAT LONG?!
What timing.
I know what the fucking timer is.
I was so confused.
I was like, what is he doing?
I thought it was like, I get activated.
Oh my god, I didn't realize.
I didn't realize that's what the move does.
I didn't watch the video.
I should have watched the video, guys.
I should have watched.
I need to just get better at dodging.
Just get better at dodging, Doki.
That's all you have to do.
Like, please.
You just need to get better at dodging.
What is your fucking moves?!
Oh my god.
Are
you serious?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, thank god.
I couldn't transform!
I couldn't transform in time.
I relied on my transformation.
I can do this.
It's not that difficult.
He broke my freeze.
He broke the freeze.
The freeze!
What do you do when he breaks?
He broke the freeze!
Please.
I froze too early.
The game didn't register his existence.
he was alive.
The game didn't register
Okay.
Okay, this time.
Full focus.
For real.
I'm gonna concentrate now.
Okay.
JK.
Guys, I'm not concentrating.
Now I am.
Okay.
No!
One.
Yes!
Goodbye!
I used the tiger!
I am the tiger!
Are you serious?
Are you fucking...
Are
you fucking...
Are you fucking...
I got the tiger though.
Guys, it's baby steps.
I caught the tiger.
I figured out.
Last try.
If I cannot...
And then I'll focus on leveling up.
If I can't do it, I'm gonna level up.
This is last try.
I think I'm just 200 level at this point.
I...
Are
you serious?
He's... I'm stuck!
Oh shit!
Oh
shit!
Oh shit!
Aww.
He literally body blocked me!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
Okay, I'll just use that to dodge.
I'll just use it to dodge, I guess.
Like, I didn't I didn't want to do anything else, clearly.
Okay.
Nooo!
I jumped too early!
I jumped too... dodged too early!
Okay, one more!
One more!
I'm getting the hang of it!
I'm getting the hang of... I'm getting the hang of it!
Last one!
If I don't do it on this try!
If I don't do it on this try, I'll level up!
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Right.
No, fuck!
Are you serious?
That didn't work!
Nothing?!
You know what?
Fuck this.
Okay.
That's fine.
I might have messed up.
Okay.
Come on!
I got halfway though!
Oh no!
I got hit by every single one!
Oh no, not this one.
Not this one!
Okay.
No.
Oh.
Okay.
No.
No!
Okay.
That
was the end!
That was the end, you bitch!
Okay.
Oh, come on!
Oh my god!
What the...
Okay.
Okay!
That's what I call a bullshit move.
You're so fucking bullshit.
Oh my god!
One more!
I'm getting better!
I'm getting better.
I'm actually getting better.
I'm locked in.
I'm locked in now.
Oh my god.
I'm actually locked in.
I'm locked in.
Oh shit.
I'm so locked in.
Okay.
I'm so fucking locked in.
Oh my god.
No way!
I time mistimed!
Okay, we're not leveling up.
We're beating him.
I mistimed it!
I mistimed the dodge!
We're not leveling up.
I mistimed the dodges.
I like understand.
I cannot... I literally just know I will not... I got the strat.
I got the strat now.
We can kill him.
We don't need a level up.
We don't need to.
I don't care if I'm under level.
I'm a gamer!
Okay.
No!
Fuck!
Okay.
That's fine.
That's not fine.
Oh my god!
I'm getting mistimed!
I'm mistiming my dodges!
Gamers never give up!
My timing!
But I know I can kill him.
I know I can kill him with the level I'm at.
I know I can kill him.
Don't give up!
We're not giving up!
I know.
I know I can beat him.
That's the thing.
Okay, new strats.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh no!
Come on!
Literally!
Yes!
Okay.
Come on!
I can't...
Okay.
That's fine.
Now we...
Okay.
That's not fine.
That's not fine at all.
We haven't mastered Tiger Form yet, guys.
We still need experience with Tiger Form.
That's fine.
We're still learning.
Okay.
Are you serious?
I dodged that.
Come on.
What the fuck did I just do there?
Oh my god!
I was like, what?
I've never seen this move before!
No!
What was that?
I didn't even know how I did that combo!
It just happened!
I was pole dancing!
True, I was pole dancing!
Oh my god, this trip will not end until I defeat this stupid dragon!
Don't ever give up!
I will not level up!
I will not!
Leveling up is for pussies!
Okay.
Alright.
No!
I can defeat him!
I'm gaming!
Fucking gaming!
Okay.
I need to remember all his combos, though.
That does that.
No!
I forgot this one!
I forgot the combos!
No!
I lost the combos!
You lost the combos for me!
They lost the combo timing!
This is it!
I will figure this out!
Alright, what if I do use... Okay, I'm gonna try the clones.
Clones, go!
Monkey, go!
Go, monkey!
Go, monkey, go!
Monkeys, keep going, monkeys!
He can't kill all of us!
Jeez!
All my monkeys are dead.
Okay.
Alright, we tried the monkey...
I don't know if the monkey strat was good.
I still don't know.
Okay.
Oh, what?!
Alright.
Immobilize!
Please!
We're so close!
Oh, transport, transport!
I figured it out now.
This is fine.
Oh, this is not fine.
It's not fine.
This is not fine.
He has the final hit!
Oh!
Okay.
No!
I forgot that!
Get away from me!
Okay.
Oh, that was my last magic.
Guys, that was my last magic.
Swing!
No!
Get away from me!
Get away!
No!
Swing!
Get away!
He wouldn't get away!
He wouldn't get away from me!
Bro!
He fucking... oh my god!
He just kept running!
Monkeys go.
Monkeys go!
We're going for him!
Monkeys attack!
Oh god.
Never back down!
Never!
Oh god.
Okay.
What the fuck?
That's not fair.
He put me in a corner.
He put me in a fucking corner!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Nice.
Clown.
Oh!
This is where I die!
This might be where I die!
I couldn't dress for him this time!
I feel... I will be so much determination!
Too greedy.
Oh my god.
Charge attack while invisible?
Okay.
We'll try that.
Go, monkeys!
Go!
We can do this, monkeys!
Apes together strong!
Apes together so strong!
Oh, I can't charge.
I can't charge.
Guys, for those who are wondering why I don't charge my attacks afterwards...
Because I can't.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Oh, not nice!
Not nice!
Okay.
Oh, he should be about 15 years old.
Okay, we can charge now.
Awesome...
So, for done!
Let's bond with mon apartheid!
Wow, Takara!
Well done to you!
Why doesn't he do anything yet?
!
Okay, goodbye wolf.
Goodbye tiger.
Okay, okay.
Tiger could not live.
Tiger, tiger had its fun.
I tried to block it before, but it wouldn't block.
I don't know.
Can I actually block that as tiger?
Did it just not work?
Charging up.
Wait, I can?
Guys, why didn't you tell me this?
Wait, I can cancel it?
I can cancel it, guys?
What do you mean?
I could have cancelled this entire time.
Now I know.
Okay.
Alright, now I know though.
That's good.
Alright.
I didn't know!
I'm stupid!
I play video games for a living!
Are you serious?
Stop!
Oh my god.
Okay, freeze.
Come on!
I just need one more hit!
Yes!
Okay!
Okay, do the charge up.
Do the charge up!
Yes!
That's fucking right.
That's right!
Boom!
Slash!
Go down!
Oh no, wait!
He gets another one!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, how did you get to do it again?
I can't believe it.
That's illegal.
That should be illegal.
Monkeys.
We'll figure out the system.
Oh no!
Oh, I forgot that move!
I forgot it does that!
Okay.
What?!
What is that range?!
Okay.
I missed.
How?
How did I miss that?
How did I miss that?!
How?!
This is bullshit!
Use your electricity, bitch.
You know you want to.
I'm saving it.
Oh, that hits me?!
Boom!
That's fucking right.
Wait, what?
Wait, where?
What happened to...
Oh, there it is.
I was gonna say, what happened to wind power?
What happened?
Fine.
That's fine.
Come on.
Okay.
Are you serious?!
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my god.
No!
Okay.
Oh
no!
No!
Oh, okay.
We'll go full.
I know he has one more move there.
Okay.
And another!
No, I don't have Roller.
I don't have Roller!
Oh!
Okay.
What?!
I'm so sad.
That's actually bullshit.
Oh my god!
That's actually so bullshit!
I'm so... I'm doing so well!
I didn't even realize I had Overheal!
I was so close!
I got grabbed!
I didn't even thought...
We were so...
I had one Overheal!
Oh my god!
Oh yeah!
That was so close!
I had... That's like the closest I've ever done to...
I'm like losing track of all the monkeys.
There's so many monkeys.
I'm losing track of them.
No!
Okay...
Fun is not the right word I would describe this boss.
Fun...
Fun is absolutely not the right word right now.
Oh my god.
I'm not doing well for this run.
This run I'm actually fumbling a lot.
I'm fumbling a lot with this one.
Oh no!
I'm so sad!
If he didn't command grab me!
If he didn't!
Oh my god!
The command grab!
The command grab was what fucked me up!
Okay, this is it.
This might not be it, but like, I'm coping.
This might not be it, I'm just coping at this point.
Oh, what?
There's too many monkeys!
I can't see where I am!
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
Come on.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, you bitch!
Are you?
Okay, whatever.
Whatever.
We're gonna do this.
It's fine.
This is not the run.
This was just not the run.
It's fine.
This was just not the run!
This is not the run!
This was just not the run.
The timing!
I freeze the exact moment he does the thing!
I freeze the moment he does it.
That's like the most tempting part.
When we, when we both looked at each other and we both freeze.
It's just not the run.
We will find the run!
We will figure out which was the run!
Aight, okay.
Our monkeys, our monkeys transported the- transported him somewhere else.
But that's okay.
That's fine.
Okay.
Oh, come on!
I thought you were gonna-
What?
That hits me?
You bitch!
I just want to make sure he doesn't do the electricity.
Oh no!
He doesn't do the electricity, but he does something else!
He hits me!
I command thee to stop!
Okay.
He does one more move.
And he does one more...
Nice.
Oh no!
No!
Oh no, not again.
Not again!
No!
I'm just going to be Tiger!
I want to live!
I can't block it!
Okay.
That's fine.
What?
This is bullshit.
We
both use Cloud Step!
The fact that we both use Cloud Step!
Here.
Big baby!
Okay.
Oh...
How do you still...?
Oh... Again!
Oh my god.
I thought he... I said he was going to use this...
I thought he was going to use it twice!
I couldn't hear!
I...
Sometimes twice, sometimes three... if it takes too long.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, bro.
I was not ready for number... I was not ready for number two.
I felt so lied to.
I heard... I heard that he only was going to do it twice, so I let my guard down.
That was my first mistake.
I let my guard down.
Oh, what the fuck?
That hit?
What?
Okay, I missed.
I don't think this is a run.
I already messed up.
Okay.
I already let my guard down, though.
Oh.
I... oh my god.
I'm just going to... I'm going to do this.
I know I wasted it, but it doesn't matter now.
It doesn't matter.
I just need to do one, and then...
Fire.
Oh, wait, no.
Come on.
Go, tiger, go!
Oh, no.
Oh, come on.
Okay, I know he has one more move.
And then that last move.
And then the one more move!
I almost forgot about that one!
Oh, okay.
All right.
I'll wait.
What?
I got faked in there.
I didn't realize that also.
I was just... I was like, okay, I'll wait then.
It'll be fine.
I'll just keep waiting, I guess.
He hit me!
How the fuck did you see me?
How did you see me?
Okay.
Oh, no.
He still hit me.
Okay.
Oh, no.
What?
Okay.
All right.
Here I go.
He doesn't see me, right?
Oh, no.
He does.
Guys, he saw me.
He saw me, guys.
I can't heal when he's...
I can't heal when he does that!
It's too fast!
When he does that, it's too fast!
He does it so fast!
No.
Don't use pluck?
Okay.
We're gonna try with no pluck then.
I don't know.
I feel like I don't really need the...
Okay.
Sorry.
I fucked it up.
I started it too early again.
I started it too early.
I started it too...
I will not give up.
I will not give up, guys.
I will kill him if I'm leveling up.
I can do this.
The moment I do this, I'm a gamer.
Because you convinced him you should...
I can't give up now!
Exactly!
I could have leveled up, like, 30 minutes ago, but it's too late.
I can't give up now.
We're, like, committed.
We're so committed.
Like...
If I give up now after doing all that...
And just leveling up, then what's the point?
Okay.
Oh.
Focus, focus, focus, focus.
Focus.
Doki.
Come on!
You're not...
Don't get hit from that!
Doki!
DON'T GET HIT FROM THAT!
Boom!
That's fucking right, bitch.
That's fucking right.
TRANSFORMATION!
It's fucking right.
TRANSFORM!
GET TIGERED!
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Slash, slash, slash, slash, slash!
Alright.
I'm gonna heal first.
He does one more move.
Two moves, actually.
I lied.
Three moves.
No!
Oh, he missed.
Again!
No, I fucked up timing.
Okay.
He does that extra move.
Yeah.
Okay, nice.
No!
Fuck!
I messed it up.
Then he does that extra move.
Okay, and then...
No!
Fuck!
Okay.
Come on.
Drink.
Hydrate.
Oh, no!
I couldn't dodge it!
No!
I'm dead!
I fucked up the last one!
The thing is, if you miss time the first one, you miss time the second last one, you get hit by the last one.
You get hit by the last one.
The mis-timing.
I almost had it.
I can do this.
Alright.
Okay.
And then...
Oh, he doesn't do the second move?
Okay.
I got so used to doing that other move.
That, like, fucks with me.
When he doesn't do it.
No!
Like, right now, it fucks with me so much.
Like, he would do that dive, but he's not doing it.
And I don't know what to do when he doesn't do it.
Oh, I wasted that.
I thought he was gonna do it!
I wasted that one.
Oh, what?
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna use this.
I legit thought out Wait, what?
Okay, that's five.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I don't think this is a run though.
I'm gonna fuck it up really badly.
Slam!
Okay.
Nice!
Oh!
No, no, no!
Not nice!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's not fine!
Okay.
What?
How did that not...
How did that not work?
Hey!
How did that not hit?
He was right there!
He was right in front of me!
Oh, he was right in front of me.
Guys, but imagine how fucking awesome it would be if I actually beat him.
Just imagine that sweet victory.
Sweet victory.
But guys, the victory would be so sweet.
Please, just think about the victory.
Okay, but what if I just use the tiger early?
Like, I don't care.
What if I just use it early?
It's okay.
He's just standing there!
It's electricity time.
Okay.
Okay, he's doing that now.
Come on.
Okay.
Okay, come on.
Come on, use your electricity.
Nice.
Oh, come on!
I jump, you jump, we all jump.
Oh, okay.
I guess not.
Okay, I guess not.
One, one, one, one, one.
No hukuna matata.
No worries.
Not allowed to have no worries.
All the worries, apparently.
All the worries!
Oh, I forgot about the second one.
Fuck.
Okay, I wish I didn't use that.
Wuka, why did you do the pull dance?
Why did I...
Why did I do the pull dance?
The pull dance.
Yeah.
Oh my god, he started pull dancing.
He was like, please, free me.
Wuka was just like, Free me.
Come on.
We can do this.
Okay.
This is not looking good already.
Yeah.
I took unnecessary damage here.
Tiger.
Fire.
Fire, fire, fire.
Okay.
I'm coming over.
Okay, we got this.
We might not got this.
Okay.
T!
That's right.
Fuck you!
That's fucking right!
You can't do anything!
Okay.
That's right.
No pull dance for you.
Sir.
You...
I'm sorry!
He just wants his pull dance, you freak!
And
sometimes it's fucking...
Okay.
The longest fucking combo of my life.
Wait, that still hits me!
Bitch!
Oh.
Don't feel good.
Don't feel good!
I'm gonna save the...
I'm saving it for when I need to heal the Cloud Step.
Okay.
Nice slam.
Wait, freeze!
I...
I don't know anymore.
Why
did I do that?
Why did I do that?
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, no.
Here I go again!
I fucked up.
I fucked it up.
I fucked it up, guys.
Ah, no!
That
move always messes me up!
That move messes me up so much!
I always mess up the timing!
I don't have Cloud Step!
I didn't have it!
Right now!
It's always that move!
Oh, my God.
Okay, I'm gonna use Cloud Step for heals only.
Okay, that's the new strat.
Cloud Step on heals only.
Okay, we figured it out.
Oh.
I can do the Tiger, though.
I learned that I can do the Tiger and have it in time.
Okay, nice.
I'm gonna use that to heal now.
And then...
Smack!
Okay.
What?
That hits me?
This fucking bitch!
Okay.
Don't have Cloud Step.
So I guess I have to hit!
Okay.
Ah!
We're not stopping until I defeat him.
We're not stopping.
Yeah, he can bleed!
He can bleed!
I don't need to over level!
I don't need it!
No!
Leveling up has been off the table since the dawn of time!
I'm a gamer!
What?
Okay.
Oh.
Concentrate.
Concentrate, Doki.
Come on.
You got this.
You got this, Doki.
Come on, Tiger.
Don't let this stupid dragon tell you what to do!
This is why they're extinct now!
All their ancestors are fucking dead!
Kill time!
Yay!
Oh.
Okay.
What's he gonna do?
Yes, he is.
Okay.
He is.
Can I get that last move too?
No.
Majority of his combos.
Oh, please.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
He doesn't know where I live.
That's so fine.
That's okay.
Okay.
The pole dancing is the death of me.
I swear to God.
The fucking pole dancing.
There's actually one fear when the monkey starts pole dancing.
Literally one fear.
Okay.
Alright.
Knocked in there.
There's literally one fear.
My only fear in this game.
Oh, no!
Alright.
Oh, no.
Tee-tee-tee-tee-tee-tee.
TEEEEEEEEEEE!
Oh my God.
Wait.
What?
Oh, it's because he charged it up already?
It's because he charged it up already!
Are you serious?
I didn't know if...
Oh, my God!
No way!
I thought I could do it at any time!
Oh, my God!
That was so close!
That threw me off!
That actually threw me off.
How do I remove pole dancing?
We need to remove at- pole dancing was a mistake.
At-pole-dancing.
Dancing was a fucking mistake.
Where is it?
Is it in this?
Oh my god, it is.
Okay, we gotta remove pole dancing.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Re-enact the sparks.
Alright, where is it?
Pillars dance.
Alright, nice.
Okay, now where do we put it though?
Wait, where should we put pole dancing?
Guys, where do we put pole dancing?
Which should be our focal point.
Maybe I should do it with magic.
I'm gonna put it on magic.
Mana.
We need more mana.
No, we need more mana.
Okay.
This is it.
Every... every fight we get stronger.
Every fight...
Every fight is knowledge.
Okay, it's knowledge.
It's knowledge gain.
Just remember that.
Tiger time.
Hey, I heard you talking shit.
I heard you talking shit.
I heard you talking shit!
Tiger time!
Oh shit, sorry.
You... wrong way.
I need you to get closer.
Heal time.
Oh, okay.
Alright, that's... that's a little awkward.
Wait.
Alright.
Oh no.
Come on.
Are you serious?
Okay.
Oh no.
Heal.
Yes!
Got it.
Come on.
Nice.
No, no, no.
No, fuck.
Okay.
It's fine.
That's fine.
Alright.
Further I am.
Let's save for out B.
Woo!
Heal time.
Freeze.
Okay.
Heal time.
Oh, he's looking at me.
I don't like how he's looking at me, guys.
Yeah.
Are you serious?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
Fuck this.
No!
I...
I pressed three!
Oh!
Little between two and three!
Oh my gosh!
He tried to climb.
My hand went through!
No!
Not the boys.
The boys.
The boys spiked me up.
You're not supposed to get over.
Oh my god.
The boys.
Bunch me up.
Boys, why you do this to me, boys?
We could have had it all, boys!
This was... that was it!
That was actually it!
That's the worst part!
When it was it!
Oh my god, when it was it!
Okay.
Oh,
I...
I mistimed that.
Okay, there we go.
That's fine.
That's absolutely fine.
It's fine.
Sick.
Alright, here we go again, I guess.
Oh my god, fuck.
I have to heal on here.
Come on, come on.
No!
I
got stuck against this wall.
The wall got me.
Never give up, Doki.
Never give up.
You are a gamer.
You don't need to level up.
If you level up, the game won't be as fun.
Because you'll just be killing everything instantly.
You don't need to level up.
Everything won't get too easy.
And what's the fun in that?
Okay.
Tiger.
It's fucking red.
I see you.
You're gonna let me tiger you!
Okay.
Focus, focus, focus, focus, focus.
You know all the patterns now.
You should know all of the patterns by heart!
Guys, I looked away.
Guys, I...
Guys, I blinked and...
What happened?
Guys,
I blinked.
What happened?
Okay, full focus.
No talk.
Doki, no talk anymore.
Come on.
Nice.
Here.
Smack!
What?
That was a full on hack.
I refuse to believe that like, literally on my screen, it shows that like, I was still invisible.
Like, I thought I was still invisible.
How do I know when I'm not invisible?
Jack is pissy!
I fucked it up.
I have to use that.
Okay.
Come on!
No!
Okay.
It's fine.
I have the heal.
What?!
No!
Oh no!
I fucked it up!
And you're like, make sure when he looks at me, then I know.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Oh!!!!!
The fired Careful!
That slamm!
That slime takes so much!
That slide!
What was that damage?!
Jack!
Thank you for....
I'm fucking feel powered up!
Thank you for the magenta super attack!
Thank you, thank you!
It's the slab.
Okay.
Oh, I should have hit him.
That was a free hit.
That was a free fucking hit right there.
Fire, fire, fire, fire.
Oh my god.
I'm a bit mad at it.
Okay.
What?
Okay, t-t-t-t-t, come on.
Oh, did I hit that head?
Yes, yes, yes, I hit.
Okay, that's good.
That's good that I hit.
Okay, nice.
That's fine.
I have full- I have heals.
Come on.
Okay.
Oh no, this is bad, this is bad.
He's doing flips with me!
Ah!
I need to get that timing!
That- that last timing always fucks me up.
The last two.
How are you still here two hours late?
This is my orphan of cause.
This is my fucking orphan of cause right now.
This is like the fucking skill jump between this guy and every other boss is actually crazy.
Like I don't understand the skill jump there.
It's- yeah, the time- it's like different timing.
So that's like the hardest part.
The fact that the timing is like- it's like different.
Oh my god, I almost thought I was gonna-
Okay, you say it's not that hard.
I wanna know what your level is.
Hahaha!
Okay.
Just look at the damage I do.
He has so much armor on him.
What?
Oh, I thought I used Cloud.
I didn't.
What's your level?
I need to know.
Why isn't it difficult for you?
Oh no.
No!
I couldn't get the fucking hair!
Oh, not the hair.
I mean the- Okay, it's over.
It's over.
I couldn't press T in time.
I couldn't press T on time.
Thank you!
Can I rebind it to- okay, I'm gonna try to see if I can rebind T to my mouse button.
Okay, I'm gonna rebind it to my mouse button.
Okay, let's see.
I'm gonna see if I can.
I don't think I can though.
I think I tried to and it wouldn't let me.
Where's T?
Where the fuck is T?
I can use mouse button?!
I can use middle mouse button!
Okay.
Bro.
Why can't-
Okay.
You can't use mouse button.
That's fucked.
That's actually fucked.
Oh, I don't know why I did that, but okay.
Okay.
Alright.
Focus, focus, focus, focus, turkey.
That's fine.
You can heal now.
Okay, I'm gonna smack him.
Okay, nice.
You can smack him.
And you can use your tagger.
One, one, one, one!
Wait, am I not?
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, good timing on that.
That's not good.
Okay, that's good.
Nice, I got the cloud in time.
Alright, this is where I die, I guess.
Okay, when he looks at me, I'll know.
Like, right now.
Okay.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Alright, I did it.
Okay, nice.
That's not nice.
Okay.
What?
That was bullshit.
That was actually bullshit!
Calm.
Calm!
So calm.
Oh my god.
God damn it.
Ttt.
Are you...
That was bullshit.
I almost got it.
Aw, I almost got the timing.
I almost got the timing.
You can do it, Dookie.
Do your best to never give up!
Only if you basically never give up once!
It was so close.
I almost got that timing correctly too.
I almost... I just needed like... I was like 0.1 second too slow.
I was actually 0.1 second too slow.
Oh, that was a dodge I shouldn't have done.
I didn't need to do that dodge.
I just want to get the Tiger out early.
Tiger.
Come on, we're so close.
Nice.
Fire, fire.
Come on, Tiger.
You got this.
Do it for the homies, Tiger.
Do it for the homies.
Nice.
Okay.
Okay, bitch.
That's actually bullshit.
That was bullshit.
They're not gonna lie.
I'll say it.
That was fucking bullshit.
Oh, okay.
That too.
That was also bullshit.
Bam.
Okay, time to die.
Time to die.
Time to die, cause I ran out of... I ran out of fucking... I ran out of fucking... Oh my god.
I was so low.
Oh no!
Holy shit!
Moro fucks me up when he does it twice!
Jesus Christ, even the smack isn't even that much.
That's like the saddest part.
Oh my god.
Do it for her!
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Maybe never mind.
Maybe not right now, though.
Maybe not right now, though, guys.
Maybe not right now.
Guys, I don't have any more gourds, guys.
Guys, I don't have any more gourds.
Oh fuck.
Oh, he's so good!
I'm going!
I'm dead.
The moment I saw the...
Oh my god.
I saw the thing and then I was like, this is how I die.
This is how I die.
Yuki, thank you for the Akasufa.
Thank you, thank you.
You got this.
Don't give up.
I got this.
Oh my god.
Every...
Every run, we get stronger.
Okay.
It's okay.
Every run, we're getting stronger.
Bye.
Tiger.
DO WHAT YOU'RE MEANT TO DO!
Oh my god, guys.
Guys, I need to turn down the effects.
I've been fighting him for so long.
The effects are breaking.
I need to lie.
Oh my god.
I've actually been fighting him for way too long.
The PC is not having it right now.
The PC is actually breaking up.
The PC is like, please.
Kill him already.
I really need you to kill him.
Nice.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Oh.
I have to restart the game?
Okay.
If I die here, I shall restart.
I guess, goodbye.
Goodbye, then.
Okay, we'll know when he sees me.
Do you think he knows?
Do you think?
Oh, he definitely knows now.
He knows now.
He definitely knows now.
Okay.
God damn it.
C'mon.
Okay.
It's fine.
That's fine.
No, okay.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm fine.
No.
Oh no!
No!
The frame!
Oh god.
Oh god, please.
It's okay.
Tiger!
Yes!
What have you done?
Oh my god.
I did it.
I was dead.
Why did everything I killed in the sand still live?
Yes, me.
Me, I will kill you in your fucking life.
Don't say that.
There's no way.
There's a face.
Ew.
There's no way.
I... whoa.
Wait, what?
What?
That was you?
Are you...
What?
These two?
There's no way.
Don't say that.
Is this my sword?
Is this...
Don't say that.
There's no face, too.
Oh, thank god.
We fucking did it.
Oh my god.
Golden thunder.
Cast worms into yellow loam.
Gaining immune shock.
We did it.
We actually did it.
Even with frame drops.
We didn't need to level up.
I told you guys.
Thank you.
I told you all.
We are gamers.
Oh my god.
I didn't even use up all my heals, too.
I fucking told you.
I knew it.
Oh my god.
I fucking knew it.
It's even good.
I don't even know.
Even with frame drops.
We gamed.
We fucking gamed.
Oh my god.
We fucking did it.
I'm so proud of us.
I knew it.
Craft weapon?
What do I craft?
I don't have...
We need one more steel.
Guys.
Guys, we need one more steel.
What do you...
Where do I get the other steel?
Could I buy steel?
Could I buy it?
Please tell me I can buy it.
Right?
I can't buy it.
Where do I...
No way.
Where do we...
There's no steel anyway.
What are we doing?
Oh...
Oh my god.
Hurry.
Last spot.
Okay, we're gonna...
Can we buy the steel from the tiger?
Back to the tiger?
Okay.
Tiger time.
Thank you.
We did it.
Was it very noticeable that I was dropping frames like fucking crazy on that boss?
Like on the last fight?
Was it...
Was it pretty noticeable?
Yeah, yeah.
The last one.
I like that like...
The last time...
The last time I fight him...
Oh, he's not even...
You guys lied.
Okay, secret.
Only chapter boss.
Guys, I'm...
We're calling it here.
We're gonna call it here.
I'm...
I'm done.
I'm not done for today.
I proved a point now.
Guys...
For anybody that says I'm not a gamer, I did not over level.
I beat...
I beat the fucking...
I beat the dragon under level.
Nobody can fucking judge me anymore.
Now, if we encounter any other boss...
If we encounter any other boss that means...
That requires me to level up, I'm going to level up.
I only need to do it once.
Okay?
To the point that I can defeat a boss.
Even if under level.
And now...
Now, I have the privilege to over level now.
I...
I now have the privilege to over level.
If I want to.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Thank you all for the super chats.
And...
I really appreciate it.
Um...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That was really a fight.
They threw everything at me.
From frame drops to everything.
They threw so many things at me.
I can't believe the...
The time I beat the boss.
When I was frame dropping so fucking hard.
Like...
I...
I can't believe that's when I fucking beat him.
Like even I was frame dropping.
Holy shit.
Alright guys.
I game through the...
I'm gonna call it here everybody.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me.
Hit the bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye bye.